EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE LIKE
TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
ASSEMBLY LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING WELL WE ARE NO
LONGER REQUIRING MASTERY ONE OF
THE CAPITAL- HE- ENCOURAGE
ANYONE TO DO A AND TO DO WHAT
THEY FEEL- IS- PROBABLY FOR
THEMSELVES FISCAL DISCIPLINE IS
STILL REQUIRED IN THE HEARING
ROOM FOR THOSE IT'S. HE'D WITH
MISSILE COMMENT ON TO MAKE SURE
YOU UNDERSTAND ASSEMBLY RULED TO
ENSURE. WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND
RUN THE FISHER AND VERY. WE PLAY
THESE ROLES ALL PEOPLE WHO TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS.
HERE TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH OF THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME.
YOU'RE NOT PERMIT CONDUCT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IN PZ ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT A CERTAIN BEHAVIOR
BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES RESIDENTS
VIOLENCE EVEN VEILED THREATS. WE
DO HAVE A FEW OP FOR TESTIMONY
TODAY. PRIMARY WITNESS TESTIMONY
IS IN PERSON THE COMMENT MAY BE
IN PERSON OR AT A REMOTE TEST
MISTER TESTIMONY STATION OR BY
PHONE. IF YOU ARE PROVIDING
PUBLIC COMMENT- WE ASK THAT YOU
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATIONAL
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
NOTHING ELSE OF THAT NOTHING
MORE THAN THAT. ARE THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE THE ONLY ONES I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO ELABORATE
ON THEIR POSITIONS. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 I ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. OR P. THE CALL NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE ALE BR NOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV. AS WELL AS ON YOUR
TV SCREEN FOR THOSE WATCHING THE
STREAM. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON
HIS BEGINNING. THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN QUEUE. BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL.
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE SEE WHO'S
MEETING A LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
AND YOUR SMART DVICES REDUCE TO
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AND NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE SORRY NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE ONE. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE ONE
MYSELF WITH A TRY TO HELP. HELLO
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THREE. THIS
MORNING TO THE POSITION LETTER
PORT ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
WE ALSO HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS
SET UP THAT YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL
TESTIMONY. OR POSITIONS THE
EMAIL IS A L. B. R. DOT
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. A. L. B. R. DOT COMMITTEE
AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA. DOT GOV.
STILL SHE DOES WORK FOR LOCAL
MIGRANTS YEAH SO WE'RE GONNA OF
THE STARS COMMITTEE OF THE
HORSES PAYER LITTLE BIT SHORT ON
QUORUM AT THE TIME AT THIS TIME.
AND- WE WILL START WITH- AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO SEVERAL
WEEKS OF ALL NOTE THAT AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WAS PULLED
BY THE BY THE AUTHOR SOME OF OUR
WORKS BUT SHE DOES HAVE BEFORE
US AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLEASE PROCEED AND I KNOW
ONE LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION
IS THAT. ORDINARY CUSTOM FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO WITNESSES.
EACH SIDE UP TO TWO WITNESSES
AND EACH WITNESS HAS UP TO TWO
MINUTES. AND SO THAT'S THE
STANDARD PRACTICE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
ALL THE TIME BUT- YOU CERTAINLY
CAN TAKE AS MUCH TIME AS YOU
NEED WITHIN THOSE PARAMETERS-
ASSEMBLY. THE FIRE AND NUMBER
STAFF AND HE FOR US. AB. TWENTY
OF CHINA AMERICA THERE WE GO
OKAY THANK YOU CHAIR- COMMITTEE
STAFF COLLEAGUES MEMBERS AND
THOSE WATCHING BY TELEVISION- AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST EMPLOYEES
BASED ON THEIR FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL ENSURES WORKING
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION TO DEAL
WITH UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES
STICKS CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH AS
CLOSURES OF SCHOOLS OR OTHER
CARE FACILITIES. FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY DISCRIMINATION
OCCURS WHEN AN EMPLOYER TAKES A
NEGATIVE EMPLOYMENT ACTION
AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE TO CARE FOR
A FAMILY MEMBER THIS INCLUDES
MOTHERS AND FATHERS OF YOUNG
CHILDREN PREGNANT BREAST FEEDING
PEOPLE AND EMPLOYEES WITH AGING
PARENTS SIX PALACES OR PARTNERS
THAT MAY ENCOUNTER FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY DISCRIMINATION
MOST EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE CARE
GIVERS. AT SOME POINT IN THEIR
PROFESSIONAL HOWEVER WORKING
MOTHERS AND PREGNANT PEOPLE ARE
MOST LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY DISCRIMINATION
WITH LOW WAGE EARNERS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR DISTRICT IMPACT. WHAT
THE **** THERE'S WERE SET THE
NINE CENTS LESS LIKE TO BE
WRECKED FOR HIGHER HALF IS
LIKELY TO BE PROMOTED AND
OFFERED AN OF A THE DOLLARS LESS
IN SALARY FOR THE SAME POSITION
AS SIMILARLY QUALIFIED ON
MOTHER'S EMPLOYEES ARE
STRUGGLING TO BALANCE THEIR JOB
. CARING FOR THAT FAMILY IS THE
A RISK OF THE SHOULD NOT. A
REASON FOR TERMINATION OR OTHER
ADVERSE EMPLOYMENT ACTION.
EMPLOYMENT ACTIONS LIKE
TERMINATION REFUSAL TO HIRE OR
DEMOTION BASED ON. A BY ISSUES
ABOUT HOW WORKERS WITH FAMILY
CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES WILL
OR SHOULD ACT WITHOUT REGARD TO
THEIR WORKERS PERFORMANCE THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS LIZ MORRIS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF HASTINGS CENTER
FOR WORKLIFE LAW AND JULIA
WORK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
RECEIVED GOOD MORNING I'M LIZ
MORRIS I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER FOR WORKLIFE LAW.
AN ASTOUNDING NUMBER OF WORKERS
LOST THEIR JOBS IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS BECAUSE OF THEIR
CARE GIVING RESPONSIBILITIES.
UNDER KOPET WORKING PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALSO CARING FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN THE ELDERLY AND FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
FACED HEART WRENCHING CHOICES.
BETWEEN PROVIDING ADEQUATE CARE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND KEEPING
THE PAYING JOBS THAT THEY NEED
TO SURVIVE. THESE CHOICES ARE
NOT NEW DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
FAMILY CARE GIVERS EXISTED LONG
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND IT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY CONTINUE UNLESS WE
TAKE AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TO
ADDRESS IT NOW. BIAS AGAINST
MOTHERS IS THE STRONGEST FORM OF
BIAS AGAINST WOMEN AT WORK IT'S
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
GENDER PAY GAP. WOMEN OF COLOR
SINGLE MOTHERS IMMIGRANTS AND
WORKERS IN LOW PAYING JOBS FACE
THE HARSHEST IMPACTS. WHEN
MOTHERS ARE FIRED OR UNABLE TO
WORK BECAUSE OF THEIR FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES THEIR CHILDREN
SUFFER WITH FOOD AND-
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER PLAGUES
OF POVERTY. SADLY CALIFORNIA HAS
FALLEN BEHIND NATIONALLY IN
ADDRESSING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST MOTHERS FATHERS AND ALL
FAMILY CAREGIVERS. ROUGHLY 30%
OF THE AMERICAN WORK FORCE IS
ALREADY PROTECTED BY A STATE OR
LOCAL LAW THAT PROHIBITS THIS
FORM OF DISCRIMINATION. AND THE
EXPERIENCE OF THESE OTHER STATES
SHOWS THAT FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES DISCRIMINATION
LAWS WORK FOR EMPLOYEES AND
BUSINESSES ALIKE. BY ENCOURAGING
EMPLOYERS TO TREAT FAMILY
CAREGIVERS BASED ON THEIR JOB
PERFORMANCE INSTEAD OF BIAS
WHICH HAS THE POWER TO BOTH SAVE
JOBS AND AVOID LAWSUITS. I TWO
THOUSAND A TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REPORT FROM THE CENTER FOR
WORKLIFE LAW FOUND THAT THE
LIKELIHOOD AN EMPLOYER WILL BE
SUED IS ZERO POINT 0001% AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO IS
IMPERATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BECAUSE IT
WILL ENSURE FAMILY CARE GIVERS
ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE FULLY IN
THE WORK FORCE. FOR FAILING
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES IS NOT A
PRIVATE FROLIC IT'S THE HARD AND
NECESSARY WORK OF CARING FOR THE
ELDERLY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AND RAISING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WORKERS THAT
WILL KEEP OUR ECONOMY GOING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JULIA
PERISH I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT WORK. A
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT THAT HAS
BEEN ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
PEOPLE WITH LOW INCOMES FOR OF A
HUNDRED YEARS. AND PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF MAYBE TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLANT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES OR THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS- FOR TAKING ON THIS
ISSUE. BECAUSE WE PROVIDE FREE
LEGAL SERVICES WE HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM FAMILIES FACING BARRIERS AT
WORK AND STRUGGLING BECAUSE OF
THE CARE OBLIGATIONS. IN SOME
CARE GIVERS WHO NEED SMALL. TO
THEIR WORK BUT ARE DENIED THE
REALITY FOR THESE WORKERS.
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW PAID WORKERS
IS THAT THEY CAN BE FIRED IF
THEY ARE LATE ONE TIME IF THEY
HAVE AN EMERGENCY AND MISS A DAY
AND THAT CAN SEND ENTIRE
FAMILIES. PUSH THEM DOWN DEEPER
INTO POVERTY THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE REAL AND WE MUST ADDRESS
THEM. WE SAW AN UNPRECEDENTED
INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR FAMILY
CARE GIVING DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND WE SAW THE RESULTS. WOMEN
WERE FORCED FROM THE WORKPLACE
IN LARGE NUMBERS CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES WAS ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS WOMEN WERE TWICE AS
LIKELY AS MEN TO SAY THEY LEFT
WORK FOR CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES. DUE TO CHILD
CARE OR PER CHILD CARE PROVIDER
OR SCHOOL CLOSURES. FOR EXAMPLE
ONE MOM WHO HAS A SPECIALIZED
NURSING CARE FOR HER DAUGHTER
BECAUSE HER DAUGHTER RIFAAT
RELIES ON A VENTILATOR IN ORDER
DAUGHTER THAT IN THE ON. MOM
REQUEST AN ACCOMMODATION BUT SHE
WAS FIRED. WOMEN OF COLOR ARE
MORE LIKELY TO WORK IN LOWER
PAYING JOBS WTH FEWER. AND HOW
LAST ACCESS HEALTHCARE. PLANS
LESS EMERGENCE CHILDCARE WHY AT
THE SAME TIME MORRIBLE AND THE
MOTHER ARE THE- READ. FOR THEIR
COMPUTER WHAT MONTHS. UNLESS WE
ADDRESS THIS. OF TO FAIL
PORTABLE IS. CONTENT YOU TABLE.
COLOR FAMILY. MOREOVER WORKPLACE
ACCOMMODATION ARE FEES.
EMPLOYERS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO.
ANY ACCOMMODATION THAT ARE NOT
REASONABLE OR THAT WOULD IMPOSE
AN UNDUE BURDEN. THIS IS A
STANDARD THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
FAMILIAR WITH FROM OTHER
CONTEXTS INCLUDING DISABILITY
ACCOMMODATIONS. I ALSO WANTED TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
CHRONOLOGY OF THE INTERACTIVE
PROCESS AND ACCOMMODATIONS
REQUESTS. THE IRAQ THE
ACCOMMODATION REQUEST DOES
TRIGGER THE INTERACTIVE PROCESS
AND THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS CONSIDER AND RESPOND
TO THE REQUEST BUT IT DOES NOT
NEED TO TAKE PLACE BEFORE THE
NEED FOR ACCOMMODATION ARISES
THE INTERACTIVE PROCESS DOES NOT
NEED TO BE LONG AND DRAWN OUT
AND IS OFTEN QUITE INFORMAL-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE. FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE PUSH TO-
IS ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO. FLUFFY GO TO THE OPERATOR
THE MODERATOR OF CP WAS ON THE
PHONE LINES. SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE THE INTERNMENT OF
SHOWS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
. FIRST AGO TO LET NUMBER THIRTY
ACRE LAND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS MARICA YOSHIHARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. RECORDED
LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MONICA'S
AMERICAN BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO TURN CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK IN FRONT OF
THE BOARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR. COLLECTOR RIGHT THIRTY
THREE ELEVEN PUBLIC AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE CALL TIME
PARTNERSHIP AND THE TIME STRUCK
THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS SEVEN AND SO
FRIEND'S COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT SIX THANK YOU.
RECTO BATTLING TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY WATER NOT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE ARE GOING STRONG
SUPPORT IF YOU TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU. BURKE MEXICO
EIGHT SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S ONE ZERO FIVE I'M WITH
PUBLIC COUNCIL AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. THANKS FOR CALLING SIXTEEN OF
THE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MALCOLM HARRIS WOULD CARRY
ACROSS GENERATIONS AND WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU. OCTOBER
EIGHT FORTY TWO IN IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS GABBY CANNONS AND I AM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BREASTFEEDING COALITION AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU
. BLACK TOTALING THIRTEEN LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MOLLY SHEEHAN THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- LOOKING FOR THE USER
OPPOSITIONTHIS IS YOUR MAKE WE
HAVE A FEW PLEASE DIRECT ME UP
I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR SUCH A TO
TAKE A ROLES BECAUSE I WAS
QUORUM. KALRA HERE FLORIDA.
JONES SAWYER. REYES ZERO HERE.
FOR THEIR- WE'VE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM AND NOW OPPOSITION- WE
GET UP TO. TWO MINUTES YOU SAY
WE GO TO SEE THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO IS A JOB KILLER AND THIS
BILL IS A REPEAT FROM AB ONE ONE
ONE NINE FROM LAST YEAR AND WE
SEE THIS SURE THE CONCERNS THAT
WE DID LAST YEAR- HIRING AN
APPLICANT BECAUSE THEY'RE A
WOMAN OR BECAUSE PREGNANT IS
OUR- LEGAL THEIR PAID SICK. CAN
CARE. AND QUITE A BIT OF OFF TO
CARE FOR CHILDREN OR OTHER CARE
RECIPIENTS INCLUDING UP TO
TWELVE WEEKS THAT CAN BE USED IN
ONE TO TWO HOUR INCREMENTS WE
WERE COULD TO THIRTY POINT EIGHT
ALREADY PROVIDES FORTY HOURS OF
LEAVE FOR SCENARIOS WHERE THERE
IS AN UNFORESEEN CLOSURE OF A
SCHOOL OR CHILD CENTER AND SO WE
CAN WORK WITH CONFI OF THESE
TIME CAP LEAVES RT EXISTS THIS
BILL CREATES A VEGAN UNCAPPED
REGIONAL COMBINATION REQUIREMENT
THAT IS TO COMMIT ANALYSIS
ITSELF NOTES IS IMPRACTICAL. IN
REALITY AND IS LIKE A CALL THAT
MORNING SAYING THEY CANNOT SHOW
UP FOR WORK IN THE BUSINESS WILL
BE FORCED TO ACCOMMODATE A RISK
CLICK IS FORMER AGAIN PLEASE K.
REASONABLE COMPANY LIKE A IS
VERY UNPREDICTABLE A VERY GRAY
AREA THE STANDARD OF WHAT IS A
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION OR
UNDUE HARDSHIP IS VERY GREAT
REALLY EXCEPT EVEN MORE SOMEONE
WAS ACCOMMODATED. IS NOT. GEN
WHERE SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE.
THERE'S ALSO NO TIME FOR INTER
PROM. IN OUR SYSTEM. FAILUE
ENGAGE IN INTERNET PROCESS OR
ALLEGE INSUFFICIENT PROCESS IS
GROUNDS FOR ITS OWN SEPARATE
CAUSE OF ACTION. FURTHER THE
DEFINITIONS OF FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES EXTREMELY BROAD
IT WOULD APPLY TO ANYONE WITH A
CHILD UNDER EIGHTEEN. ANYONE WHO
CARES FOR SOMEONE IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLD AND THAT ANYONE CARES
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER. THE FAMILY
MEMBERS NOT ACTUALLY LIMITED TO
A FAMILY MEMBER IT INCLUDES
ANYONE OF THE EMPLOYEES
CHOOSING. ACCORDING TO THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF WORKERS HAVE A
CHILD UNDER EIGHTEEN WHEN YOU
ADD IN THESE OTHER GROUPS OF
PEOPLE YOU GET CLASS IT IS QUITE
BROAD. MAKING IT VERY EASY TO
TRY AND CLEAN THE ANY ADVERSE
ACTION WAS ACTUALLY TAKEN BASED
ON FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES NOT
JOB PERFORMANCE OR ANOTHER
REASON. AND FOR THE RIGHT I
THINK THIS BILL WE'RE PUTTING
ANOTHER VAGUE MANDATE AND-
EMPLOYERS THAT. THE SORE OF
LITIGATION THE OFF A LOT YEAR
THAT MISSION WHEN PREVALENT
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN IN STATE. OF
THOSE ARE STATES WITH THIS LAW
HAVE A REASON MORE MIDEAST
REQUIREMENTS. INFERRED UNITED
STATES THE LIKELIHOOD THE LEAST
FOR. BY IS OF. SENT BEFORE THE
ACTUALLY OVER FIFTY. PER AND
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO KNOW. YOU
KNOW. YEAR AND WITH BILL WAS
THROUGH MULTIPLE. MEMBERS FROM
BOTH PARTIES EXPRESSED CONCERNS.
INCLUDING THREE DEMOCRATS AND
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY- THAT
BASICALLY SAID THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SEE CHANGES BEFORE THIS BILL
HEADS TO THE FLOOR. AND I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN NO CHANGES MADE SINCE THOSE
X. CONCERNS WERE EXPRESSED LAST
YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'VE
BEEN THINKING FOR RUSHING
THROUGH AYE AYE I WANNA MAKE. AS
IS NORMALLY THE CASE FOR EQUITY
PURPOSES OF YEAH. HAVE FOUR
MINUTES MOTHERS WITH THE TWO
WITNESSES OKAY YEAH THEY DID
JUST FOR FAIRNESS BOTH GET FORM
. USUALLY WE HAVE TO WOULD WITH
THERE'S JUST ONE. YOU CAN TAKE
IT BUT YOU CAN TAKE A BREATH
OKAY. THANK YEAH. I'M NOT GONNA
CUT YOU OFF ABRUPTLY THERE'S
JUST WAY WITNESS OKAY. THANK IS
THERE ANYONE. OF HERE. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. UP TO AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO. OKAY OF MODERATE
IF WE CAN GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE AT
THIS TIME. FOR TOTALING FORTY
FOUR LANES OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED
TO AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO FOR
THE REASONS STATED THANK YOU
PLEASE. MAKE THE FORTY NINERS
FOR REFERENCE THIRTY FIVE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU GOT IT
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
STATE FORGET FUND BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED
BENEFITS AND STUFF THEY GIVE
MONTHLY. TO DOESN'T REGULATE
FIFTY THREE AWARENESS OPEN
PLEASE GO. AHEAD MY APOLOGIES
PRESIDENT SUPPORT MARTIN FOR THE
ON BEHALF OF NAY ROW APPROACH
CAL. AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT FOR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. AB THE MEASURE MEMBER JAMIE UP
WITH THE CHECK THIRTY OF
CALIFORNIA IN RESPECT OPPOSITION
ITSELF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RECORD TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MEGAN
COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SEVERAL AND FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY NO GAP THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FEDERAL ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIVER FOR THE COMING TO THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING ABOUT MANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTIONS. OKAY THE
MOTION AND A SECOND. HE WILL
ALSO BE COMING OKAY- I KNOW THIS
IS THE SECOND EFFORT AS IS
REFERRED TO AND SO- GOOD LUCK.
IT DOESN'T ENJOY- AND I
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY- WITH THE MOTION FROM
DECEMBER REYES SECONDED BY SOME
MEMBER WARD- CENTER WHICH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST- WOULD
RESPECT THE ASTOR OF IVOTE HAPPY
TO SIT DOWN THE CHAMBER AND TALK
THROUGH SOME OF THE CONCERNS
WE'VE WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO IT AGAIN- YOU
KNOW AND ALSO AROUND SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AROUND YOU KNOW.
THERE'S LEAVE IN THERE ARE IS
LEE BUT THEY WOULDN'T COVER A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE- THROUGH AND MAKE
SURE WE HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY
FOR THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW AT A
DAY CARE CLOSES BECAUSE THE
POWER GOES OUT YOU NEED TO
SCRAMBLE TO GET YOUR BROTHER TO
TAKE CARE OF YOUR KID YOU GOTTA
STOP THEM ACROSS TOWN YOU NEED
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY MINUTES OR
AN HOUR. THAT'S THE TYPE OF THE
OR TALKING ABOUT SO THEY WOULD
BE PENAL FOR TRYING TO SPIN ALL
THE PLATES THAT A LOT OF YOU
KNOW WORKING WORKING FAMILIES
ARE DEALING WITH- BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YEAH THANK YOU LAST COUPLE
YEARS OF TELL US A LOT ABOUT
THESE DIFFERENT DEFINITION AND
HOW LIFE. YOU JUST VERY QUICKLY
. I SAW THAT A MESSAGE THREE.
WILL ON THE ON A- TWENTY VOTE
FOR. TWO ONE EIGHTY TWO. MOTION
IS DEEP TO JUDICIARY CALL I
KALRA HI FLORIDA. FLORA NO JONES
SAWYER REYES. FIVE REYES ICE
ARDAL KNOW C. R. O. NO WAR. WARD
HI. IT'S WILL PLAY A PLACE THAT
ON CALL THESE WERE MORE LOOK
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A DIFFICULT
EMOTIONALLY CAN CAL. RIGHT SO
IT'S OF NO AS AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY. FOR SOME MEMBER LEE. OF
MASS TAKE WILL ON THE CAN
CALENDAR PLEASE. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. TO APPROVE. COMMITTEE%
KALRA I KALRA FLORA. FLORA HI
JONES SAWYER REYES. REYES I
SEYARTO HI ZERO I. WARD HI IT'S
ME IT'S CONSENT TO THE FOUNDERS
. WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM FOUR FROM
SOME I A LOT OF GARCIA WAS WITH
US. AB TWO FORTY THREE AND-
PERCEIVE AND EVERYBODY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB.
TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE BILL THAT
AIMS TO PASS THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD. TO CONSIDER
MAKING CHANGES TO THEIR HELP HE
ILLNESS STANDARDS AND THEIR
WELFARE SMOKES DOWN- TO FOR THE
- OUR WORKERS FROM EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS I DON'T THINK I NEED
TO GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE. LIST
OF REASONS WHY THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO STEP IN. FOR SOME
KIND. FROM THE BOY AND SO WITH
THAT I'M GONNA ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ARE TWO WITNESSES TO KEEP THE
CAR BRIEF AND- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BUT THE MOTION IS SET FOR
THE SECOND. YEAH PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS I'M ERIN
RODRIGUEZ CALIFORNIA POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS ON TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWO FOUR THREE AS YOU
KNOW OUR STATE'S HEAT WAVES ARE
BECOMING LONGER AND HOTTER WHICH
INCREASES THE RISK OF HEAT
RELATED ILLNESS OR DEATH FOR
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THIS ISSUE IS EXPECTED TO GROW
WORDS WILL CONTINUE CLIMATE
CHANGE RECENT DATA SUGGESTS THAT
THE RATE OF HEAT RELATED
ILLNESSES AND INJURIES ON THE
JOB IN CALIFORNIA DECREASED
AFTER THE CURRENT RULES WENT OF
. THE SUBJECT THE WATER FOR
IMPROVEMENT RESEARCH BY I OR HAS
SHOWN. WITH KEY AND THAT. FIVE
HI. EXPECTED IS THREE. MORE
BETWEEN NOW AND MID. SUCH HOT.
CONDITIONS PRESIDENT THREAT TO
WORKER. THIS BILL A BETTER PART
OUTDOOR. FROM THESE HARMS AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SHARE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JAY GARNER THEM A POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN EASTERN COACHELLA
VALLEY'S. AND INLAND CALIFORNIA
MANY AGRICULTURAL WAREHOUSE AND
OUTDOOR WORKERS ALREADY%
REGULARLY BRAVE TEMPERATURES
UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED DEGREES
WELL DOING MODERATE TO SOME
SENSE OF WORK. THIS IS A SPECIAL
IN DOES IT IN A CIRCLE. WHERE
TEMPERATURES REGULARLY EXCEED A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DEGREES. THE
INTENT THIS BILL PROTECT
INCREASE SINCE. THIS AND- IT'S
ALL HIGH TEMPS AND WHILE. IS IT
PART OF POLICY. AROUND CLIMATE
OUT OF AND EXTRA WEATHER OF.
RUEFUL TO THE OFFICE START THIS
NECESSARY. FOR THE CONSIDERATION
OF THIS. TEMPERATURES IN THE
EASTERN GHOUTA VALLEY AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THIS BILL AND
OTHER EXTREME HEAT RELATED
POLICIES. WE NEED COMMONSENSE
PROTECTIONS THAT INCLUDE
MANDATORY PAID REST PERIODS
AVAILABLE COLD WATER THE
MANDATORY SHEETING OF WORKERS
DURING HIGH HEAT. ACCESS TO
EMPLOYER PROVIDED AND NINETY
FIVE MASK DURING WILDFIRE SMOKE
EVENTS ARE ALSO AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
WORKERS. ULTIMATELY ALTER HIGH
HEAT IN A QUEUE I LEVELS
REPRESENT CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH
WORK SHOULD BE STOPPED OR
MINIMIZE. WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE ALREADY FACING THIS
CONDITIONS LEGISLATURE SHOULD
NOT AN ACT WHICH- THE NEW. ARE
AVOIDED AND MITIGATE THE MUCH
AS- WHERE'S THE DIXIE THE PER
HEALTH THREATS OF EXTREME EVENTS
. AND MAKE CAL CHAMPION OF AND A
LEADER IN PROTECTING WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITIES FROM THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS. CENTERING THE
VOICES OF IMPACTED WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURING THAT
REGULATIONS AVOID UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT THEIR FAILED
TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT WORKERS OR
CREATE OTHER PROBLEMS.
LEADERSHIP GOT EXCITED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE AUTHORS
OFFICE ON IMPROVE COMMUNITY
DRIVEN PROTECTIONS FOR WORK
DURING EXTREME HEAT AND WILDFIRE
SMOKE EVENTS. IDEAS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MIKE
MONICA BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
APPROACH TO PROTECT WORKERS HER
DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE. IF NOT
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES. SIR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONES
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE FELT.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONLY PROVIDE A LEAD MEMBER FOR
THE NEXT QUESTION OR COMMENT.
EXCELLENT THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS THE
WINDOW THAT YOU GET CALLING FROM
THE FALCON VALLEY IN SUPPORT FOR
A B. TWO TWO FOUR THREE. THANK
YOU. MEXICO GROWING TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
YOU'RE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
MOUNTAINOUS IS NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB CHOOSE THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THIS BUT NINETEEN
NEARLY IS OPEN GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KELLY RATHER- AND I AM A
COMMUNITY MEMBER OF SACRAMENTO.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT- SB THREE TO
FOUR THANK YOU. THE CURRENT
TWENTY LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THE FIFTY HEY KATHY
AM BAKERY NINETY INSTITUTE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO
FOUR THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TOTALING FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ANDREA AND I'M
CALLING FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA I
AM A DAUGHTER FARMWORKERS AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NO ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I'M WILL GO
AHEAD AND- SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE- ACTUALLY REMOTE TEST MY
STATION HAVE BEEN ASKING ABOUT
THAT. BUT PRESUMING THAT
INTEREST SOMEONE THERE THEY
WOULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING BUT I
MEAN JUST CALL THAT OUT RIGHT
NOW AND WANT SUPPORT REMOTE TEST
MUSICIAN. THAT'S THE RETURN WAS
MET MY FOR MYSELF. OKAY SO- YEAH
WE NOTICED THAT AS A POTENTIAL
OPTION TO THE PUBLIC SO WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE WITH THESE- KEEP
MENTIONING THAT AS A YOU KNOW TO
MAKE SURE NO ONE'S THERE- AND SO
NOW WILL GO ON TO OPPOSITION ON
THE BE- TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
RUBBERMAID FOR CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB TWO TWO
FOUR THREE I'M BEFORE I TOUCH
INTO CONCERNS ON A FLIGHT WE'VE
ALREADY SPOKEN TO THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AT SOME LENGTH AND
APPRECIATE THOSE TALKS- WE HOPE
TO MOVE FORWARD OF IT WITH THEM-
BRIEFLY I WANNA A FLAG THAT THE
MUCH OF THE TESTIMONY HAS
FOCUSED ON THE CHANGES TO THE
OUTDOOR HEAT REGULATION THAT
CORPORATE IN THE BILL. MOST OF
OUR CONCERNS COME WITH THE OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE BILL THE BILL
ACTUALLY TOUCHES ON MULTIPLE
REGULATIONS MAKING CHANGES ARE
CONCERNED CHANGES RATHER TO THE
OUTDOOR HEAT REGULATION AS WELL
AS THE WILDFIRE SMOKE REGULATION
AS WELL AS PROPOSING THREE NEW
REGULATIONS FOCUSED ON A
COMBINATION OF HEATING PIECE
RIGHT. MOST CONCERNED HIS
MANAGER. AND TIME- I DID GET IN
CONTACT WITH THE WALL. FIRE
SMOKE STANDARD. DOES CONTACT
HERE. AE THE WILD FIRE SMOKE
STANDARD PRESENTLY IN EXISTENCE-
EMPLOYEES ALREADY ENTITLED AND
NINETY FIVE MASK. AT ONE STAGE
YOU AYE HITS ONE FIFTY. SO
ADDING THERE WAS SOME TESTIMONY
AS TO ACCESS ISSUES. EMPLOYEES
ALREADY ENTITLED TO THAT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS SAYS IT WOULD
LOWER THE MAXIMUM PRECAUTION
THRESHOLD TO TWO HUNDRED. THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
MAXIMUM PRECAUTION THRESHOLD ON
THE REST OF REGULATION. IS WHEN
EMPLOYEES MUST WEAR AND NINETY
FIVES AND ALSO MUST BE FIT
TESTED IN MEDICALLY EVALUATED
FOR THEIR NINETY FIVE WHICH
INCLUDES. WHICH WOULD CONCERNED
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF YOU MUST
SHAVE YOUR FACE A FIT TEST IN
NINETY FIVE. THIS WAS
EXTENSIVELY DISCUSSED AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEETINGS ON THIS
REGULATION. AND I WOULD SAY THIS
ONE THE K. WHICH- CHOOSE. A LOW
LEVEL OF ACCESS TO NINETY FIVE
AT ONE FIFTY. BUT A HIGH LEVEL
FOR MANDATORY USAGE AT FIVE
HUNDRED- WE GREAT CONCERN THIS
BILL WOULD REWRITE THAT BALANCE.
BUT DIGNIFY LOW. AND ALSO CREATE
POTENTIAL COMPETITION ISSUES FOR
NINETY FIVE. WITH THE INDUSTRIES
THAT I THINK WE ALSO COME OUT
LAST TWO YEARS. REALLY THE FRONT
LINE HA HOSPITALS AND OTHERS BY
GREATLY LOWERING THAT THRESHOLD
WE'VE- I'M RACES THE OTHERS OFF
AS WE LOOK FOR TO TALKING ON IT.%
I DON'T LIKE TO FOR- OR NUMBER
THANK HELLO. PROPOSED IN TALKS
THE LAW NUMBER OSHA FORWARD
DRAFT ANY POINT WAS A FIVE.
HUNDRED FOR MAXIMUM THRESHOLD.
THIS BILL GOES BELOW THAT- I'D
ALSO LIKE TO FLAG- AS TO THE
THREE PROPOSED OTHER REGULATIONS
THIS BILL FLEISCHER
CONSIDERATION WHICH IS I. P.
STRAIGHT INTO HEAT RELATED
STANDARDS RELATED TO TRAINING AT
FIRST DATE- IT IS OFF OF
REVIEWING THE LEGISLATION AND WE
FIGHT THIS IN A LETTER. ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES RELATING TO FIRST
AID AND TRAINING ARE COVERED IN
EXISTING OUTDOOR HEAT
REGULATION. THERE'S ALREADY
MANDATORY TRAINING THERE WE HOPE
TO DISCUSS WITH THE AUTHOR WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR CHANGES
BECAUSE THAT'S ALREADY COVERED
BY EXISTING REGULATION FOR OUR
READ- AND THE LAST POINT AS THE
PEACE RIVER BELIEVE THAT'S
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF CALLOSUM
WHICH IS TRADITIONALLY FOCUSED
ON. ON ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS AND
NOT- KIND OF RATE OF WORK BUT
WORK WE WILL TALK ON THAT POINT
AS IT GOES FORWARD- FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AB TWO TWO FOUR THREE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK UP AGAINST- IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
. ANYONE OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. FIVE MISTER MODERATOR-
ANYONE OF THE PHONES IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
THREE. THE GOVERNMENT TO FIX OUR
POSITION PLEASE PRESS FOUR ZERO
AT THE TIME. FIRST FEDERAL AND
FORTY SIX REALIGNMENTS. FORTY
SORRY. WELL I'M THIRTY FIVE
ELEVEN THE BILL HAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS FAITH
FORGES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY
APPROACH FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY MR MCKEE. THANK YOU
. THE CURRENT FORTY FOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FOR THE
REASONS STATED. THANK YOU. RYAN
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WHERE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEXICO CAROLINA
LEVIN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RECOGER LATE FIFTY NINE YEAR
THAT IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JAMIE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS AND WERE AND WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO THIRTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND MATTHEW
ALLEN OF WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NOTATIONAL LINES AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WHAT WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES I'LL
GO AHEAD AND COMMENT ONLY
BECAUSE I'M- HE DARN FAMILIAR.
WITH THE ISSUE OF FACEMASK FACE
PIECES AND NINETY FIVE MASKS
USED IN WILDLAND AND ALSO- IN IN
OTHER ENVIRONMENTS- I CAN TELL
YOU THE FIRST THING THAT MOST OF
FIREFIGHTERS WANT TO DO WHEN A
GUN FIRE IS- GET THAT MASK OFF
SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO WORK-
ESPECIALLY IN THE WILDLAND- IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT. TO WEAR THAT
MASK. AND BE ABLE TO PERFORM THE
WORK BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE GOING UP THE HILL WITH A
HOSE PACK- YOU ARE CONSUMING A
LOT OF- A LOT OF AIR AND YOUR
BODY NEEDS A LOT OF OXYGEN AND
WHEN YOU'RE RESTRICTING IT WITH
THE MASK. BECAUSE NUMBER- EVERY
OF MINUTES FOR MINUTES IN OTHER
WORDS YOU WILL NOT BE EFFECTIVE
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT OSHO WAS
RECOGNIZING WHEN THEY SET THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY DO AN OSHA
IS VERY VERY- THEY'RE VERY
DILIGENT WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING AT
STANDARDS IT'S VERY HARD TO THEM
SOMETIMES WE FEEL THAT SOME OF
THEIR STANDARDS ARE
UNREASONABLE- THE TESTING FOR
THESE IF IT'S NOT DONE CORRECTLY
OPENS UP EVERY AGENCY TO
LAWSUITS- AND IT'S NOT A- EASY
PROCESS. IT'S NOT A CHEAP
PROCESS IT'S VERY VERY COSTLY-
AND HAS TO BE DONE ONCE A YEAR
AND IT DOES NOT GUARANTEE THAT
THE PERSON HAS THE PROPER FIT IF
THEY LOSE WEIGHT. OF THEIR OF
CONFIGURATION INTERFACE CHANGES
THEN THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT PROCESS AGAIN. SO YOU KNOW
A LOT OF THIS IS REALLY
PROBLEMATIC- I THINK OSHA SET
STANDARDS FOR PURPOSE AND- I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO-
TO NOT GO BEYOND AN OSHA. AND
TRY TO LIVE. THESE TYPES SAFETY
HAZARDS FROM FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AS OPPOSED TO AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS ALL ABOUT
WORKER SAFETY AND- SO FOR THAT
REASON- I'M GONNA BE OPPOSING
THE BILL. THANK YOU. REWARD
THANK YOU ONE THINK THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS BILL FOR NICE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
APPLAUDED. RECOGNITION THAT AS
OUR CLIMATE CONTINUES TO CHANGE
AND AS WE ARE FACED WITH NOT
JUST A THREAT THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY BUT INCREASED THREATS-
COMING OVER TIME- WORKING ON
EXTREME HEAT ISSUES AND- REALLY
WORKING ON ASKING- SAID TO
UPDATE SOME OF THE STANDARDS I
THINK IS THAT WHAT THIS BILL IS
A TALENTED CATALYZE. I'M
ENCOURAGED TO NOTE YOUR WORKING
. GETTING DOWN TO SOME OF THE
DETAILS- AND WE THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE PARTICULAR MATTER-
ISSUES AND WE SEE YOU KNOW
NUMBERS THAT ARE ON THERE
REMINDING THEM A KEY ALLY. OF
TWO HUNDRED- WAS A LITTLE BIT
ABOVE WHAT I THINK WE WERE EVEN
EXPERIENCING HERE DOWN THE
SACRAMENTO BASIN. LAST SUMMER
DURING THE CALDOR FIRES AND WE
COULD SMELL THAT AND WE CONTAINS
THAT. AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT A
CONDITION THAT'S EVEN HIGHER
THAN THAT AS WELL. I MEAN THIS
IS ABOUT PROCRIT PREVENTING KNOW
. THANK YOU. FONG PIECES THAT
ARE GOING BE COMING FROM THE
KINDS OF EXPOSURE- THIS ISN'T.
TO ME FORWARD- BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON
MUCH OF THIS DETAIL- BUT WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO ADAPT. THE
WORKERS CONDITIONS SO THAT THEY
CAN- WORK SUCCESSFULLY AND
HEALTHFULLY IN IN WHAT MIGHT BE
A CHANGING ENVIRONMENT RIGHT
AROUND IS SOMETHING. THAT ALMOST
. THERE YOU HAVE ON YOUR
EXCELLENT- ANY OTHER QUESTION I
WOULD SAY LOOKING UP WOULD I I'D
SERVE FOR SEVERAL YEARS ON OUR
BAY AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT BOARD IT TEARS WELL
EARNED A LOT ABOUT PM TWO POINT
FIVE AND- DAMAGING IT IS AN FIVE
IT IS A- VERY HIGH NUMBER. THERE
MAY BE ARGUMENTS AS TO TWO
HUNDRED WOULD HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT
WAS NECESSARY BUT AND NINETY
FIVE IS AN EXCELLENT.
TRANSACTION A THAT PARTICULAR
MATTER- AND THIS ISSUE AND IS
FAR TOO. FAR TOO IMPORTANT- YOU
KNOW FOR US TO NOT MOVE FORWARD
ON AND I REALLY APPRECIATE FOR
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT
THOSE THAT ARE. THERE AND THERE
IS CHANGES BETWEEN A POINT AND I
CAN BE PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
OF SOME OF THE FIREFOX OR SOME
THAT'S A FARM. THAT'S A WILL BE
THE DENTIST OF- EIGHT TEN HOURS
AND- AND DIFFERENT EQUIPMENT
THAN A FIREFIGHTER MAYBE. THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM OR- I'M
THINKING ABOUT AFTER THE
HORRIBLE FIRES IN PARADISE AND-
MY IT'S ALL THESE INTERVIEWS OF
THESE WOMEN THAT ARE GOING IN
AND CLEANING UP AT THE- END OF
THE OF THE SMOKE IN THE AIR. SO
THESE THAT. ON A- I HOPE THAT AT
LEAST OR ON THE SAME PAGE. THAT
WE NEED TO DO MORE AND THAT THAT
MORNING YOU DONE. IF THERE IS A
SENSE FROM THE CHAMBER THAT THIS
ISN'T THE- RIGHT WAY TO DO IT
THERE COULD BE SOME MOVEMENT.
FANTASTIC BUT I THINK THAT A
SUMMARY. THAT HAS- IDENTIFIED AN
ISSUE THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. THAT POP TOO MANY
WORKERS ARE SUFFERING THROUGH.
AND FOR THAT REASON I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL AND THE
RECOMMENDATION SO. THAT I COULD
YOU PASS. TO APPROPRIATIONS I
HOPE THE CONVERSATION CONTINUES
AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND- WE
HAVE A MOTION COMES. REYES BY
SUPPORT. NUMBER LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRED THANK
YOU TO- PULL COLLEAGUES SPOKE
MATTER. I HAD. GOOD COMMERCE
WITH THE D. ABA AS SECURITY THE
CALCHAMBER LEADING PLETHORA OF-
ORGANIZATIONS- AND OPPOSED THE
BILL I THINK ONE THING THAT
WE'VE HEARD IS THAT NO ONE IS
OPPOSED TO RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM- I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY TO
HELP US GET TO A PLACE GIVEN HIS
EXPERTISE IN THE FIVE FIVE-
SPACE- TO PERHAPS SET US URGE
THAT ARE ABLE TO DO. OCCUPATIONS
ARE BUT I HAVE NOT BE ONCE A- WE
SHOULD NOT BE CONCERNED ABOUT
EXTREME HEAT ARE QUALITY ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER FRESH COLD WATER
DURING THESE TIMES- THAT THE
WEATHER CAN EXCEED. HUNDRED AND
TWENTY- AND PEOPLE ARE STILL OUT
THERE WORKING SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND I
INVITE- ALL OF THE- STAKEHOLDERS
WHO HAVE TAKEN AN OPPOSITION
POSITION COULD BE MY COLLEAGUES
ARE FROM WESTERN PSYCHOLOGY TO
JOIN US AND HELP SHAPE THE
POLICY TO REFLECT THE PROBLEM
THAT EVERYONE I THINK HERE IS
RECOGNIZING TODAY WILL OF THE
DID OR NOT. THANK YOU. TAKE A
ROLL THE FOUR EIGHT. TWENTY
FORTY THREE. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA I'VE
KALRA AYE FLORA FLORA NO JONES
SAWYER REYES SEYARTO NO SEYARTO
NO WARD WARD I WAS ON. SO THAT
WOULD BE PLACE ON CALL. THANK
YOU- UP NEXT AB TWENTY TWO OH
FOR A SUMMER BOERNER HORVATH.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO GET SET
UP THEIR. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY
TWO OH FOUR WOULD CREATE WOULD
CREATE THE OFFICE OF CLEAN
ENERGY WORKFORCE WITHIN THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY TO MONITOR TRACK CARBON
NEUTRAL PROJECTS AS OPPOSED TO
CREATE A ROBUST WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY TO SHIFT A
NEW ECONOMY. AB TWENTY TWO OF
ALSO CREATE A CLEAN ENERGY WORK
FOR SPORT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
GOOD GOVERNANCE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ABOUT PEOPLE. THERE
MANY EFFORTS REACHED INSIDE I
DID. FROM FUELS TO A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE TO READ VISITORS
GOALS AND WHETHER THAT'S SB ONE
HUNDRED TARGET OF A 100% NOBLE
ENERGY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
REDUCING COULD YOU HAVE
EMISSIONS AND WE PUT THAT LATELY
EXPANDING ZERO XIN VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PEOPLE GOODS AND
A IT'S A THAT WE STATE OFFICE
THE WHOLE ALL OF. BOTH FOR THIS. FOR WHICH IS COORDINATION WITH
RELEVANT IS THE AGENCY MYSTICAL
WITH MY AND TRACKED HER NEUTRAL
PROJECT INCREASE WORK FOR
DEVELOPMENT TO SUPPORT WORK
FAMILIES CAN COMMUNITIES THEY
TRAIN TO SUSTAINABLE AND
EQUITABLE CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY
THE OFFICE AS BOARD WILL ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT RENEWABLE PROJECTS ARE
BEING BUILT THE WORKFORCE IS
PREPARED AND WE WILL FACTORED TO
MEET OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE. AS A
- THE CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF OUR PLANET FOR OUR CHILDREN
AB TWENTY TWO OH FOUR WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT WE REACH OUR GOALS
AND LEAVE THE PLAN. BETTER THAN
WE ARE RESPECT ASK FOR A AND I
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES I WROTE
THE BILL MYSELF SO. WHAT WELL I
KNOW IN THAT CASE. WHAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY BEFORE. ANYONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. THEN
WAS MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES AB TWENTY TWO OH
FOUR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ENTER ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
PURFLING FIFTEEN LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNDEFINED IAGO
WITH CALIFORNIAN BY MENTAL
VOTERS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
SELF. THANK YOU. MOTIVATIONAL
LINES AT THIS TIME SO ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE TWENTY
TWO OH FOUR. ANYONE OF THE
REMOTE DECIMALISATION. AND
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
LOBBYIST POSITION AB TWENTY TWO
OH FOUR. THE IN THE TREMENDOUS
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WELL- ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. WELL I APPRECIATE YOU
ST RIVER ACCORDING FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD JUST WITH YOUR
FINGER UP LIKE THAT'S CONFUSING. I KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THIS IS
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT SO MANY OF
US TO TALK ABOUT IN RECENT YEARS
SO I APPRECIATE YOU. TAKING THE
LEAD IT IS CONSISTENT WITH SOME
OF THE- THE I KNOW SOME OF THE
ITEMS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET IN TERMS OF THE DIRECTION
AND- OF ITEMS THAT WE PUT FORTH
AS WELL AS LEGISLATURE- AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO TRY TO
CONSOLIDATE ALL THAT. ACTUALLY
MORE ORGANIZED FASHION- FOR MORE
DETAILED INFORMAL CONVERSATIONS
AND ORGANIZATIONS SO- WITH THAT
YOUR NEED WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE TABLE WHICH I TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I. THE
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY. I'M EIGHTY
TWO TWO OH FOUR. WELL PLEASE.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASS TO YOU
COMMITTEE KALRA HI KALRA ICE
FLORA I'D JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER I REYES SEYARTO NUMBER
SEYARTO NOT VOTING WARD WARD HI
. IT WAS OUT YOU. IT'S. I AM I
MIGHT AS WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WE
WILL DO A MEDINA IS BILL AND
WHAT THEY DO THAT YEAH WELL HE'S
NOT HERE. MISTER. ANYWAY ABOUT
UP THERE AND DO A ITEM NUMBER A
AB TWENTY ONE THREE BY SOME
MEDINA WITH THE READ THAT AS A
RECOMMENDATION TO PASSAGE OF
PROBES. THE. OVER YEAH MOTION
THE SECOND MOVING ALONG HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
EITHER NUMBER SEVEN ONLINE.
EIGHT THAT'S AB. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY THREE TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRPERSON AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA- THIS
SIMPLE BILL MERELY CHANGES THE
DEADLINE TO WHICH AN EMPLOYER
MUST PAY ALL WAGES DUE TO THE
NEED THE NEW CHIU. OF EMPLOYEES
HAVE BEEN DISMISSED FROM
EMPLOYMENT SPECIFICALLY THIS
LOWERS THE PAYMENT PERIOD FROM
SEVEN TWO HOURS TO FORTY EIGHT
HOURS FOR SEASONAL POP AND THE
CURING CANNING OR DRYING OF AN
ANY VARIETY OF PERISHABLE FRUIT
FISH OR VEGETABLES THIS ENSURE
THIS ENSURES THESE EMPLOYEES ARE
PAID IN A TIMELY MANNER. WHEN
DISCHARGED ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE MEDINA- STUFF YES WE VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO HAVE
ANY- PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THREE. SEEN ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
CNN MODERATE REVENUE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY ONE TO
THIRTY THREE POINT OF THE BOOK.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
LINES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WENT OPPOSITION
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. CNN WAS
MODERATE TO HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHERE
PROVIDE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
. C. NINE ELEVEN WE NEED TO
MOTIONS. PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. J. WHICH I WAS EXACTLY
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
ABSOLUTELY PLEASE CALL. MOTIONS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KALRA HI KALRA HIGH
FLORIDA NO FLORIDA NO JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I REYES
SEYARTO VOTING SEYARTO NOT
VOTING WARD. WARD I AND THAT
BILLS. THAT BUILDING CALL THANK
YOU YEAH I HAVE- MORE SO I THINK
I WAS GOING TO LINE. AN INMATE
AB TWENTY TWENTY NINETY FIVE.
NUMBER NINE YEAH. SO- I'LL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH THAT ONE
ALREADY FURTHER AUTHORS. SO-
RICHARD THANK YOU SO MUCH AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE WILL
REQUIRE STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR LARGE EMPLOYERS WITH
A THOUSAND OR MORE EMPLOYEES TO
ANALLY ANNUALLY REPORT TO THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY CRITICAL DATA RELATED TO
JOB QUALITY SUCH AS INFORMATION
ON PAY ADVANCEMENT AND BENEFITS.
THESE METRICS WOULD THEN BE MADE
AVAILABLE ON THE AGENCY'S
WEBSITE WITH THE INTENT TO USE
IT TO ESTABLISH AND ADMINISTER A
HIGH ROAD EMPLOYERS PROGRAM IN
WHICH QUALIFIED EMPLOYERS WOULD
BE ENTITLED TO CERTAIN STATE
BENEFITS. THIS BILL ADOPTS A KEY
RECOMMENDATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE OF WORK COMMISSION TO
ADVANCE JOB QUALITY BY LINKING
STATE SPENDING TO QUALITY JOB
CREATION. WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY. UNLIKE LAST
YEAR AND BASED ON FEEDBACK
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE MEETING WITH. AB TWENTY
NINETY FIVE IS AN IMPROVED AND
MORE BALANCED VERSION FIRST. AB
TWENTY NINETY FIVE PROVIDES MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THE HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYERS PROGRAM. THIS INCLUDES
LISTING EXAMPLES OF INCENTIVES
SUCH AS PROCUREMENT CONTRACTS
TAX EXPENDITURES AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING. AS WELL AS
SPECIFYING A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT INCLUDE BOTH
BUSINESS AND LABOR TO PROVIDE
INPUT IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
PROGRAM. SECOND WELL EQUITY
MEASURES WILL STILL BE REQUIRED
TO BE REPORTED AND COUNTED
TOWARDS AN EMPLOYER'S OVERALL
SCORE. THIS RAW DATA WILL NOT BE
MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON THE
AGENCY'S WEBSITE. THIRD WE
REMOVE METRICS THAT EXTENDED
PAST STATE LAW. SUCH AS THAT OF
. A PARENTAL LEAVE- LASTLY BE
EXEMPTED TEMPORARY STAFFING
COMPANIES FOR THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. ULTIMATELY AB TWENTY
NINETY FIVE IS DESIGNED TO
REWARD EXEMPLARY EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE TREATING THEIR WORKERS WELL
AN APPROACH THAT IS CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH THE STATED INTEREST
A MAJOR BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE. WORKERS CONSUMER
PAUL CONSUMERS POLICYMAKERS AND
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THESE
BUSINESSES OPERATE ALL HAVE AN
INTEREST IN SEEING HOW COMPANIES
TREAT THEIR OWN EMPLOYEES
ACCORDING TO A SET OF OBJECTIVE
MEASURES. IT'S TIME WE DEVELOP A
NEW SOCIAL COMPACT FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS BASED ON AN
INCLUSIVE VISION IN WHICH
EVERYONE SHARES IN ECONOMIC
GROWTH. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS INDIRA MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR.%
AND UP FELLOW MEMBER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S SPEECH OF OUR
COMMISSION A CALIFORNIA STATE
CONTROLLER BETTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY NAME
IS ANDREW MCDONALD WITH THE
OFFICE OF STATE CONTROLLER BETTY
AS A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION CONTROLLER USE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
NINETY FIVE WHICH ESTABLISHES A
FIRST IN THE NATION POLICY
ALIGNED WITH THE COMMISSION'S
GOAL TO RAISE THE STANDARD IN
CHAIR OF QUALITY JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY NINETY
FIVE APPLIES STRICTLY TO LARGE
COMPANY AND PROVIDES ACCESS TO
IMPORTANT WORKER RELATED
INFORMATION SUCH AS WAGES AND
BENEFITS HUMAN CAPITAL METRICS
DISCLOSURE IS THE FIRST STEP IN
THE CREATION OF A HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYER CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
INTENDED TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
SUPPORT COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
RIGHT BY THEIR WORKERS WHILE
INCENTIVIZING BUSINESSES THAT
ARE LAGGING BEHIND TO DO BETTER.
AN EASY TO READ NUTRITION LABELS
FOR MAC WOULD MEASURE HOW A
COMPANY MANAGES ITS GREATEST
ASSET ITS WORK FORCE IN SERVE TO
INFORM THE INTERESTS OF MAJOR
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS WORKERS
CONSUMERS IN SERVICE LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THE COMPANY
OPERATES. PLEASE INFORMATION
WILL HAVE. IMPACT YOUR MIND THE
- AT A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA IS
POISED TO DIRECT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER LARGE
SCALE INITIATIVES. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE HUMAN OF THE HUMAN
CAPITAL MANAGEMENT COALITION
INCLUDING CO FOUNDERS
PALLISTER'S IN CALPERS I'LL THE
RULE MAKING PETITION UNITED
STATES SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION. TO EXPLAIN OF THE
INVESTOR CASE. THE DISCLOSURE OF
HUMAN CAPITAL MANAGEMENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE F. C. C.
FINALIZE REGULATIONS TO REQUIRE
HUMAN CAPITAL DISCLOSURE.
HOWEVER THE RULE MAKING IS
LIMITED IN SCOPE AND ALLOWS
MANAGEMENT WIDE DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE WHICH DATA IS REPORTED
AND THE RULE DOES NOT REQUIRE A
UNIFORM SET OF BASELINE
INFORMATION. THAT IS CONSISTENT
INCOME PARABLE. IN HELPING TO
DEVELOP THIS BILL WE
COLLABORATED WITH THE DRUNK THE
DRUNKARD INSTITUTE AT CLAREMONT
GRADUATE UNIVERSITY AND ROAD
TESTED THE METRICS CONTAINED IN
THE BILL WITH A HANDFUL OF LARGE
COMPANIES TO ENSURE THE METRICS
CAN BE RECORDED. WITH BURDEN.
NATIONALLY WE ARE MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION THIS BILL WOULD TAKE
US FOR EXAMPLE THE INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS SO IF YOU TAKE A
STANDARDIZED DATA DRIVEN
DISCLOSURE REGIME COVERING WAGES
DIVERSITY. EQUITY ON PAY
TRAINING AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
MORE THAN A HUNDRED COMPANIES
HAVE AGREED TO THIS ARRANGEMENT
AB TWENTY NINETY FIVE STANDS TO
PUT THE STATE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS BROADER MOVEMENT WELL
MOST IMPORTANT IN ENCOURAGING
CREATION OF HIGH QUALITY JOBS
OUR- AS FOR THE GOVERNOR FEATURE
WORK AND HOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DIALOGUE WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINETY FIVE. C. NINE
WE'LL GO TO THE MODERATOR
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINETY FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THIS TIME WE
HAVE BURLINGTON Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVED OPPOSITION
ANYONE OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
NINETY FIVE. ONE. IF THE
GOVERNMENT PUSHUP POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD- MATAMATA
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA DO-
TESTIMONY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FIRST. START WITH. GOOD
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINETY FIVE AS A JOB
KILLER I DO WANT TO FIRST OF
COURSE THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE
IN THE SPONSOR FOR ENGAGING WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND WE DO INTEND
TO CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE CURRENT LANGUAGE WE DO
REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED I'M ALL
I DO NOT DOUBT THAT THE
MOTIVATION BEHIND A LOT OF THIS
IS TO IN FACT REWARD GOOD
BUSINESSES ARE PERSPECTIVE IS
THAT THIS BILL IS REALLY GOING
TO DO SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT.
THE STATED GOAL IS TO CREATE A
RANKING SYSTEM TO COMPARE
COMPANIES- INTO USE THAT RANKING
SYSTEM TO DETERMINE WHO IS A
HYBRID OR LOW ROAD EMPLOYER
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF DETAIL
PROVIDED BY THE STATE INTENT IS
THAT THE RANKINGS WOULD BE USED
TO DETERMINE WHICH COMPANIES ARE
WORTHY OF STATE CONTRACTS TAX
BENEFITS OR OTHER SAY
OPPORTUNITIES. REALLY STATE
REDDING. CAN THE BILL IT WILL BE
LABOR UNION ACTED. AND OTHERS
AND ONE PLAYER REP. ARE
TECHNICAL INCLUDED. BASED ON
EXPERIENCE WE DON'T REALLY
BELIEVE THOSE VOICES ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE HEARD.
AND ALSO WON'T NECESSARILY BE
THE STATE DECIDING WHO'S
ENTITLED TO THE STATE
OPPORTUNITIES. THE BILL PROVIDES
OF THE STATE MY ACTUALLY
CONTRACT THAT PIECE OUT TO
UNIVERSITIES AND NONPROFITS SO
THIS BILL IS TAKING A RANKING
PROGRAM. BASICALLY PUTTING IT IN
THE HANDS OF THEIR PARTIES NOT
THE STATE. THE DATE OF THESE ARE
COMPANIES ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
INCLUDES DATA FOR THEIR ENTIRE
UNITED STATES WORKFORCE. WHICH
WE DO NOT BELIEVE PROVIDES AN
ACCURATE REPRESENTATION OF HOW A
COMPANY TREATS ITS EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYERS THE MAJORITY OF
EMPLOYEES IN STATES OF FLOOR
MENTAL WAY TO LOWER COSTS OF
LIVING. WILL LOOK LIKE THEY HAVE
LOWER MEDIAN PAY COMPARED TO
THEIR PEERS. AND EVEN IF ONLY
LIMITED TO CALIFORNIA IT IS
DIFFICULT TO FIND A WAY TO
ADEQUATELY AND FAIRLY COMPARE
BUSINESSES ACROSS VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES. EVERY COME. COULD BE
. BUT THEY HAVE TO BE COMPARED
TO ONE OF. SO WILL IN. BE BE
PAINTED AS LOW ROAD EMPLOYERS.
NOT ONLY WILL THOSE COMPANIES
LOSE OUT ON STATE BENEFITS PLANS
ATTORNEYS WILL SURELY COME
KNOCKING ONCE THEY SEE THIS
DATA. FOR EXAMPLE COMPANIES WITH
HIGHER NUMBERS OF CONTRACTORS
ARE SURE TO FACE MISS
CLASSIFICATION CLAIMS. THE MEDIA
WILL ALSO BE READY TO WRITE ITS
HEADLINES AGAIN COMPANIES OF
LOWER MEDIAN PAY THAN ITS PEERS
EVEN IF THEY ARE DOING GREAT
OVERALL. WILL MAKE THE HEADLINES
REGARDLESS OF THE REASONING
BEHIND THAT P. DATA OR WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE COMPARED TO OTHERS.
FOR THIS REASON WE URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. YES RESEARCHER
KRISTA KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. AND I'M GOING TO THE
PHONE LINES WAS MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. FIRST IN TWENTY SIX
YEARS LATER. BERLIN FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LARA QUE NO BACKLIT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. NUMBER NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OF. OCTOBER NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK SIXTY
THREE ALIGN ITSELF OF THIS BUT I
HAD. MISTER CHAIR STATE MCCARTY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. CORRECT FEDERAL
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ZERO EIGHT FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU. RECTORY THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS MATTHEW
ALLEN WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. SACRAMENTO A TWENTY SIX
ELEVENTH OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY SIX THE MUTE YOUR PHONE
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO EIGHT SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAKE IT MORE FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. NO ADDITIONAL LINES
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
ANYONE OPPOSITION SEEN NONE
COMMITTEE A QUESTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SOME SORT OF
GOT A COMMENT QUESTION SO. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA IS OUR
BUSINESS CLIMATE. AND IT'S NOT
ALL ABOUT JUST READ IT RETAINING
THE EMPLOYERS THAT WE HAVE AND
WE'VE HAD AN ACCIDENT OF SOME
PRETTY STRONG EMPLOYERS. IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS BUT IT'S ALSO
THE ATTRACTION OF THOSE TYPE OF
EMPLOYERS IN THOSE TYPE OF
EMPLOYER THAN TALKING ABOUT ARE
THE ONES THAT CAN BRING MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF JOBS. TO COMMUNITIES
AND TWO REGIONS THAT NEED
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF JOBS IN ORDER
FOR US TO BALANCE OUT OUR
COMMUTING- OUR OUR HOUSING NEEDS
ALL OF THESE THINGS DEPEND ON
THIS BALANCE. AND IT WHEN I SEE
MEASURES LIKE THIS- AND WHILE IT
MAY BE THE FIRST IN THE NATION I
ALSO SEE THAT IS WHERE THE
GUINEA PIGS. AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE CAN AFFORD TO BEGINNING
PEGS ANYMORE- ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
WHEN IT COMES TO ATTRACTING
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA THANK
AND IT TRACKING CORPORATIONS
THAT BRING THOUSANDS OF JOBS
HERE. BECAUSE WHEN YOU PILE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS ON TOP OF
ALL OF THE OTHER REPORTING AND
REGULATIONS AND SHAMING AND ALL
THESE OTHER REGULATIONS THAT WE
HAVE WE WALKED UP WITH NOTES
THANKS AND THE ONLY JOBS WE DO
HAVE. OUR LOWER LEVEL RETAIL
TYPE JOBS THAT DON'T PAY PEOPLE
ENOUGH TO RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
AND SO WHEN I SEE. THE MEASURES
LIKE THIS THAT'S WHAT MY CONCERN
IS THAT WE ARE WE ARE DRIVING A
WEDGE BETWEEN US AND ALL THESE
OTHER KIDS ALL THESE OTHER
STATES. OUR TRACTOR THE- THAT WE
SHOULD BE JUST BY THE NATURE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING WHAT IT IS AND
WHAT IT HAS TO OFFER PEOPLE-
WE'RE BECOMING LESS AND LESS
COMPETITIVE YEAH AND I DON'T
THINK THIS HELPS IN THAT
RESPECT- YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
THAT WE WANT. OUR OUR PEOPLE TO
TREAT THEIR EMPLOYEES WELL IN A
LOT OF THE EMPLOYERS THAT SOME
OF THIS IS AIMED AT A REALLY
GOOD EMPLOYERS. YOU SHOULD HEAR
SOME OF THE BENEFITS THAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES GET THERE ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE TALK ABOUT HERE.
BUT THE MORE WE DO THIS THE LAST
. APT TO MAKE THAT FINAL
DECISION WHEN THEY HAVE A LIST
OF FIVE PLACES TO GO SET UP
THEIR CORPORATION OR THE COMPANY
OR THEIR EXPANSION. THAT LIST
MORE MORE EXCLUDES CALIFORNIA
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD THAT. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I'M I'M OPPOSING
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN VISITORS CHAIR WHICH I CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IS
INDICATED YOU KNOW THERE HAVE
BEEN AMENDMENTS SINCE LAST YEAR-
TO NOT REQUIRE COMPANIES REPORT
ON DATA NOT REQUIRED BY LAW
WHICH WAS AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
CRITICISMS FROM THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- IT TO NOT HAVE THE
DATA PUBLICLY DISCLOSED- THESE
ARE COMPANIES THAT THOUSAND AND
MORE- EMPLOYEES THEY ALREADY
HAVE. PERSONNEL THE ARCTIC SHOT
THIS DATA AND I KNOW THAT-
CONTROL YOU HE'S BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
WONDERFUL COMPANIES- THAT ARE
HEARINGS IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN- IN THIS
PROCESS AS WELL AS THE BY
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF AGAIN
CREATING INCENTIVES FOR HYBRID
EMPLOYMENT. AND YOU KNOW THE
TALKING POINT THAT SOMEHOW
CALIFORNIA DRIVE AWAY JOBS THE
DATA SHOWS OUR ECONOMY IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST IN THE WORLD IT'S
GOTTEN THAT WAY OVER THE LAST
FOUR DECADES AS WE'VE ALSO RAISE
MINIMUM WAGE AS WE'VE ALSO HAD
BETTER WHAT WORK AND SAFETY
STANDARDS YOU CAN DO BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS YOU COULD BE A
GREAT PLACE FOR EMPLOYERS. AND A
GREAT PLACE FOR WORKERS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD ALWAYS
STRIVE TO BE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANKS VERY MUCH WE USE
THEM. THE SECOND. THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY HELLO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO COMMITTEE KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORIDA NO FLOOR NO
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
REYES. YES I SEE I DON'T KNOW
CYRANO WARD. AT THOSE ON CALL.
THANK YOU IT'S BILL'S UNCLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THOSE
VICE CHAIR AND WILL HAVE A MOON
MAJORITY LEADER OF GO AHEAD AND
I KNOW SHE HAS HER OWN BILL AS
WHAT WAS ONCE BUT SHE'S
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH
REGUS AND- ARE YOU GOING TO
START WITH THAT ONE OF YOUR OWN
I WILL START WITH RODRIGUEZ OKAY
SO THIS WILL BE A AB TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN- BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OF
RODRIGUEZ PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN IS A WORKER
PROTECTION BILL. IT WOULD
ADDRESS A SPECIFIC PROBLEM WHEN
AN EMPLOYER WITH A POOR WORKERS
COMP RATING. RECLASSIFIED ASEMPLOYEES THROUGH A STAFFING
AGENCY TO REDUCE THEIR WORKERS
COMPENSATION POLICY COSTS. THERE
ARE SOME STAFFING AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE CREATED A
NICHE. INDUSTRY BY SELLING THEIR
ABILITY TO LOWER EMPLOYERS
WORKERS COMP COST. THEY DO THIS
BY ASSUMING EMPLOYEES FROM
CLIENTS EMPLOYERS WITH BAD TO
WORKERS COMP RATINGS. THE
EMPLOYEE THEN HAS A LOWER
WORKERS COMP PAYMENT THAT DOES
NOT REFLECT WITH THE EMPLOYEE
ACTUALLY DOES FOR A LIVING.
INSTEAD OF WORKING TO GET A
BETTER WORKERS COMP RATING BY
REDUCING WORKPLACE INJURIES.
THESE BAD ACTORS EMPLOYER BAD
ACTOR EMPLOYERS ARE USING THIS
LOOPHOLE TO AVOID HIRE WORKERS
COMP COSTS. THIS BILL WOULD
SIMPLY STATE THAT IN CERTAIN
CLASSIFICATIONS OR CATEGORIES.
THE EMPLOYER HAS TO BE THE ONE
TO PROVIDE THE WORKERS COMP
COVERAGE. IF IT IS THEIR CORE
BUSINESS. THE AUTHOR WANTED TO
CONVEY. THE AUTHOR MEANING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ. WANTED TO CONVEY HIS
THANKS TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORK WITH.
ONE IT'S I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
MARK NOBODY. REPRESENTING THE
SPONSOR THE FORCE WHICH IS A
COMPANY THAT HIRES VETERANS
ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS. HI YES MY NAME IS
MARK NOTABLY ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF
BEFORE SANK- AS WE WERE
DESCRIBED AND THE COMPANY WAS
STARTED WITH AN IDEA- THAT IDEA
WAS TO TRY AND FIND EMPLOYMENT
FOR UNEMPLOYED ON TERRY
VETERANS. ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS OF
THE NATIONAL GUARD AND FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS OF MILITARY
PERSONNEL- WE STARTED THE
COMPANY ABOUT TWELVE YEARS AGO
AND LITTLE DID WE KNOW THAT WE
WERE GOING TO BE BECOMING A
STAFFING COMPANY AND TRY TO DO
THAT- THROUGH THE YEARS WE WERE
EXPOSED TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT-
OR CALL THEM TACTICS. OR ACTORS
IN THE STAFFING WORLD- THEY WERE
TAKING ADVANTAE OF WHAT WE SAW
AS A LOOPHOLE AND- THIS IS- OUR
ATTEMPTS. TO TRY FOR SOME FOLKS
AND SEE CAN'T CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE- WERE MOSTLY HERE FOR
ANSWERING ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU GUYS MIGHT HAVE.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT. BUT AB TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN. ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. DOT WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ANYONE IN
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
HELLO AND THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
. THANK YOU. OPPOSITION ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PLEASE- BEFORE THE OPPOSITION I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
COMMITTEE KNEW THAT WERE WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING WITH OTHER
PEOPLE- TO TRY AND FIND GOOD
LANGUAGE MORE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THANK YOU THINK THANK YOU FOR
THE FEEDBACK. MICROBES AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALVARY STAFFING.
IN THE AMERICAN STAFFING
ASSOCIATION WHICH COMPRISES THE
TWO TRADE ASSOCIATIONS FOR THE
TEMPORARY STAFFING IN STRING
CALIFORNIA AND- AND I WILL-
MISTER NOBODY'S CRACKED AND WE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO- TO- THE
SPONSORS- SINCE BEFORE THE BILL
WAS INTRODUCED- THIS BLL I
THINK YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN DOUBLE
REFERRED TO YOU GUYS ARE HEARING
A QUICK. AND IT WAS AMENDED ON
THE TWENTY EIGHTH AND IT'S THE
THIRTIETH AND- AND WE HAVE A- WE
HAVE A- ZOOM CALL SCHEDULED WITH
MR LOCALLY IN THE END AND- MY
CLIENT AND THEY'RE- AND- THEY'RE
SMART PEOPLE AND- THERE AND- SO
THERE'S A REAL ISSUE HERE. WE
WANT HELP SOLVE IT. WERE
SCHEDULED TO HAVE A PHONE CALL
ON WEDNESDAY. AND IN WE WILL DO
THAT- BUT THE BILL IN PRINT. I
JUST BECAUSE WHAT I NEED TO SAY
THE BILL IN PRINT IS NOT THE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM THAT'S
BEEN OUTLINED THERE IS A PROBLEM
OUT THERE THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED
IT'S COMPLICATED PROBLEM
INVOLVES A LOT OF. PEOPLE
INVOLVED INSURERS INVOLVED FOR.
MEN INVOLVED THAT THE STAFFING
COMPANIES THEMSELVES. THERE IT
IS THIS IS A TERRIBLY COMPLEX
ISSUE- THERE'S THIRST. MEMBERS
OF OUR ASSOCIATION THAT WE THAT
TO. AND THEIR. ACTORS IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND WE WILL TO FIX IT-
BUT THE BILL IN PRINT I NEEDED.
IT REALLY MAKES IS THAT THE IN
PRINT THIS IDEA OF CARING THE
CLIENTS WORKERS BECAUSE- YOU.
CARRYING THE CLIENTS WORST
CERTIFICATE THAT'S NOT THE
SOLUTION IN THE WORLD WILL WORK
TO FIND A SOLUTION AND WE DON'T
WANT. THIS BILL IN PRINT TO GO.
MUCH FURTHER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE MODELS NOT
POSITION. A GOOD AFTERNOON
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MR
ROPES AND AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS BEING
PROACTIVE ON REACHING OUT WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH THEM
ABOUT YOUR THE SAME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL AND PRINT AND
THAT IT WILL INCREASE COSTS- ON
GOOD ACTORS AND DOESN'T ACTUALLY
KIND OF TARGET THE BAD ACTORS
THAT WERE REALLY LOOKING AT HERE
IN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUE.
IF ANYONE ELSE THE AUDIENCE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN. ANYONE OF REMOTE
CUSTOMIZATION. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
SIX FOURTEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FIRST TOTALING FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE LORD GAVE HIM BACK
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- WE'RE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THE BILL ON THE
AMENDMENT WE DEFINITELY HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WHAT TO GET ON THE
RECORD TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE LOWER
PROVIDE THE LINE NUMBER FOR THE
NEXT SEMESTER.
THERE'S A- ONE RIGHT OVER THE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
STEVE MCCARTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE NO FORMAL POSITION RIGHT
NOW WE ARE REVIEWING THE
MEASUREMENTS. SHOW CAPTION IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE DOCTOR THANK YOU. WE
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OF FOR MANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR MOTIONS. BUT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. OKAY GLAD TO HEAR
THAT. THERE SEEMS TO BE
AGREEMENT THERE IS A PROBLEM
THAT'S ALWAYS THE FIRST STEP TO
ADMIT THERE'S A PROBLEM AND IT
SEEMS LIKE BOTH SIDES SEE THAT
AND HOPE WE CAN DO TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ARRIVE AT A COMMON
SOLUTION- THE RECOMMENDATION IS
DUE PASSED TO INSURANCE
COMMITTEE THE MOTION FOR SUMMARY
VERSION SAWYER SECONDED AND
WARD. ASSEMBLY RAISES LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ FOR NIGHT VOTE THANK
YOU OF SEXUAL PHYSICAL. MOTION
IS PASS TO ENSURE CAN KALRA I
KALRA AYE FLORA. LARA NONVOTING
AYE REYES ICY ARCTIC NO SEYARTO
NO WORD WORD HI. THOSE OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PART OF THE NEXT
BILL- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE
AB. TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS. AT THE BEGINNING OF
OCTOBER NINTH AT THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN ORDER TO
PROTECT WORKERS EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SIGNED INTO AND THEY WERE SIGNED
INTO LAW THEY REQUIRED EMPLOYERS
TO REPORT REPORT COPE WITH
NINETEEN WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS TO
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
TO NOTIFY WORKERS OF A COVERT
NINETEEN EXPOSURE IN THE
WORKPLACE. TO THEIR PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE WHICH
SIMPLY EXTENDS THE PROVISIONS OF
THOSE BILLS. WITHOUT ANY ACTION
THESE CRITICAL PROTECTIONS WILL
LAPSE AT THE END OF THE YEAR AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE WHAT
WILL PROTECT WORKERS BY
EXTENDING THE SUNSET DATE OF
THESE PROVISIONS UNTIL JANUARY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WE
HAVE SEEN JUST HOW BADLY COVERED
NINETEEN INFECTION SPREAD IN
CALIFORNIA WORKPLACES AND HOW
WORKERS PAID THE PRICE FOR THESE
OUTBREAKS WITH THEIR HEALTH AND
WITH THEIR LIVES. WHILE WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE IS A NEW. AND HIGHLY
CONTAGIOUS SUB VARIANT. CAUSING
A SURGE IN EUROPE. AND WE ARE
TRYING TO PREPARE FOR THAT. AS
THESE NEW VARIANTS SPREAD WE
WANT TO PROVIDE PROVIDED THE
PROTECTIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAVE AB.
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF OUR JAZZY.
GROW LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR U.
F. C. W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
AND TO MITCH STEIGER IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS CAN GET
GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JACKIE GRAY WELL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH UFCW
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL. UFCW
REPRESENTS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND THE FOOD
PHARMACEUTICAL AND RETAIL
SECTORS ALL OF HIM WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WITH
GREAT RISK TO THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. FIRST HE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE MAJORITY
LEADER FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING WORKERS THROUGHOUT
THIS THAT THE PANDEMIC AND
ENSURING WORKERS HAVE THE MOST
BASIC A PROTECTION. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED HOW WE
PASSED THAT AND GOT INTO LAW
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE AND
SUBSEQUENTLY CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
FOUR. AND AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE WHAT EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. CALIFORNIA IS
MOVING TOWARDS A NEW PHASE IN
THE COPA NINETEEN FIGHT THAT
PLACES TESTING VACCINATION AND
SUPPORT FRONT AND CENTER. EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE TRACKING GIVES
THE STATE KEY DATA ON WORKPLACE
OUTBREAKS SO WE CAN FOCUS OUR
RESOURCES EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF HOPE IN NINETEEN. AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY THREE WILL ENSURE
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE KEPT IN
PLACE AS COVERT NINETEEN
VARIANTS CONTINUE TO RAVAGE OUR
STATE. THE NEXT OF A NINETEEN
VERY IT CAN SHOW UP AT ANY TIME
AS WE'RE SEEING IN EUROPE AND WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ACT OR GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS EVERY TIME A
NEW VARIANT ARISES. WE MUST BE
PREPARED TO REACT IMMEDIATELY TO
STOP THE SPREAD AND SENDING THE
SUNSET ON WORKPLACE TRACKING AND
NOTIFICATION OF COPING I THINK
YOU SAYS. IT'S CRITICAL TO DOING
THAT. I MEAN. AND SEXUAL P. OF
OUR COAL. PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND
HAVE PROVEN INVALUABLE TO
KEEPING WORKERS SAFE. FOR THESE
REASONS AND MORE WE RESPECT
THEIR REQUEST- I VOTE ON AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE TODAY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED BY
THE AUTHOR AND PREVIOUS WITNESS
WE WERE JUST REALLY EMPHASIZE
THE POINT THAT. THE PROTOCOLS AT
ISSUE IN THE BILL'S MENTIONED
ARE A KEY PART OF WHY WE'RE IN A
BETTER POSITION NOW THAN WE'VE
BEEN. AT ANY POINT IN RECENT
MEMORY AND- SOME THINGS ARE
BETTER BUT SOME THINGS ARE WORSE
AND IF WE WERE TO LIFT THOSE
PROTECTIONS. PREMATURELY WE
DEFINITELY DO RUN THE RISK OF
SENDING US BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE- AS WAS MENTIONED THE
VIRUSES MORE TRANSMISSIBLE THAN
IT THAN IT'S EVER BEEN NOW
ESPECIALLY. USE OF IT TAKING
OVER. THERE ARE TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE
STILL TOO YOUNG TO BE
VACCINATED. ROUGHLY 7% OF THE
POPULATION TO MIDDLE COMPROMISED
ON THE WINDOWS OF THE VACCINE
WORKS THAT WELL FOR THEM. THERE
ARE STILL A LOT OF REASONS TO
WORRY THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
REASONS KEEP THESE PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE AND WE URGE OUR SUPPORT
MUCH. THERE'S A ONE IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT. AB. TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINISTS UNION
UNITE HERE AND UTILITY WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANKS MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LIVING COSTS THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATIVE
BOARD SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SO WHAT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY NINE THREE. IT'S NOT
JUST MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. FIRST
TOOK LITTLE LINE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BIG PICTURE MEMBERS INTAKE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTY
COUNCIL DALY COUNTY FEDERATION
OF LABOR AND UNITE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CURLING SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
DUCKS SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OCTOBER NINTH
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS AND STAFF. BOB
MAHER CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SOLUTION. BOB WHAT I
CAN ONLY JUMP AHEAD. YOU KNOW
WHAT I'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE WHY
NOT I'M BEING NICE TODAY.
OPPOSITION YES PLEASE YOU ON
BEHALF OF THIS AND I APPRECIATE
THE- OUR- GOVERNMENT YOU FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE- FIRST
OF LIKE A WE HAVE SPOKEN THE
OFFICE OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS
REGARDING OUR CONCERNS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
WE SHARED READ LINES THIS WEEK
AND HOPEFULLY. THAT WILL MOVE
FORWARD- I WANT TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON THE THINGS THAT ARE NOT AN
ISSUE FOR US I THINK THE- THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED- NOTICE ABOUT
BREAKS TO THE COUNTIES IN THOSE
POINTS. OUR CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL IS REALLY FOCUSED ON ONE
PIECE WHICH IS THE ONGOING
PROMISES WIDE NOTICE THE MUST BE
GIVEN AS WELL ON WITHIN ONE
BUSINESS DAY WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT PIECE REALLY DOESN'T. ISN'T
NECESSARY GOING FORWARD I'LL GET
INTO WHY BUT AS TO THE NOTICE TO
COUNTIES AND CLOSE CONTACT
TRACING RIGHT NOSE NOTICES. THAT
IS NOT WHAT WE'RE OPPOSED TO
HEAR- SO I THINK THAT THE REAL
ISSUE KEY ISSUE FOR US IS THIS.
WE ARE NOT OF THE SAME SITUATION
WE WERE IN THIS BILL IS PASSED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. WE HAVE
VACCINATION NOW WE HAVE A HIGH
VACCINATION RATE RELATIVELY
NATIONWIDE RELATIVELY HIGH. THAT
WAS NOT IN THE FACT THAT-
THANKFULLY WE HAVE RETROVIRAL
DRUGS THAT ARE BETTER WE-
DISTRICT. AND HOSPICE RAISE THE
GUN DOWN. THEY'RE TREATING THIS.
WE ALSO HAVE A GOVERNOR NOTING
THAT WE THE STATE IS MOVING
TOWARDS AN ENDEMIC STATUS. I
WHICH WAS DENOUNCED I BELIEVE
SIX WEEKS AGO. SO WE REALLY LOOK
AT THIS AS A POINT WHERE TO SAY
.
HERE WE HOPE THAT THROUGH
DISCUSSIONS WE CAN FIND AN
APPROPRIATE SHIFT DOWNWARD AS
YOU MAKE THAT TRANSITION- I'D
LIKE TO- YOUR- THE OTHER POINT I
MAKE AND I TOTALLY AND I'M SURE
MANY OF YOU EXPERIENCE THIS IS
THAT THESE PROMISES WHITE
NOTICES THE MUST. AND ON THE-
HAVE. ANY OF MY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES REALLY BECOME JUST
ANOTHER PIECE OF ANOTHER PIECE
OF SPAM THEY RECEIVE EVERY DAY
THAT THEY DON'T READ. AND TO
THAT POINT I THINK THAT
UNDERLIES A LARGER CAN A LARGER
CHANGE IN. FOCUS WHICH IS.
HEARING THERE IS A CASE IN THE
WORKPLACE THE PASSED THROUGH THE
WORKPLACE NOW IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO IS DIFFERENT THAN IT WAS IN
TWENTY TWENTY. RIGHT THOSE WERE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY WE REACTED
DIFFERENTLY NOW I THINK THE
PERCEPTION OF RISK. ACCURATELY
AMONGST THIS THING AND
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE IS
DIFFERENT. AND I THINK THAT OUR
GOALS OF THIS NOTICE REFLECT
THAT CHANGE IN PERCEPTION AND
CHANGE IN SCIENCE- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE. YES MISTER CHAIR CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S BILL. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ANOTHER REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. SO MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONES IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHAKE UP THE SYSTEM
PLEASE PRESS ONE POINT ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. FIRST
TOTALING THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS FAITH
FORGET ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IN THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA EXACTLY ABILITY FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED BY MR
MAITRI. THANK YOU. RECORD LIKE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. REX
OVERLAND FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NORTHGATE
NOVEMBER CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MEXICO GARLAND THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW ALLEN WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SEVERAL AND NINE NINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THE
BROWN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE-
MOTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FEDERAL ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN RESPECTFUL
UP SYSTEM FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY MR ELECTRIC THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEVEN ADDITIONAL
LINES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE CAN BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTIONS. THAT'S WHAT IT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- WHILE WE ARE NOT FULLY
OUT OF THE WOODS ON THIS YET AND
I THINK THAT TWO YEAR EXTENSION
OF THIS- IS THAT CREDIBLY
REASONABLE- NO ONCE DISAGREED
THAT IT'S THE RIGHT OF OTHER
EMPLOYEES TO KNOW IF THEY WERE
EXPOSED. TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
THEIR OWN PRECAUTIONS WHAT ALL
THINGS ARE BETTER ACROSS THE
BOARD PRESS FORTUNATE. YOUR HAVE
IN THIS WAY. AS A POSITIVE
CHOICE DO. A TAPER. IN THE FORMS
OF VACCINATION. OR MASKING OR
WHATEVER ELSE THEY CHOOSE-
KNOWING THAT- ARMS AND JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO BE ABLE TO
HOW THEY SHOULD RESPOND ON THEIR
DATE. THE BUSINESS- AND AS WE
CONTINUE TO SEE VARIANTS COMING
GO. UNTIL THIS IS FULLY I THINK
WORK THROUGH OUR POPULATIONS-
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL JUST TO KEEP EVERYBODY
SAFE- FORTY BUT WE'VE ALSO. TO
BETTER PROTECT SOME OF THE
EXPOSURE NOTICING. STEP PARTY
INDOOR OVER THE LAST. AND I
THINK THIS IS A REASON- REQUEST
GOING FORWARD TO KEEP US ALL.
JUST A LITTLE BIT SAFER SO- I'M
I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL PARTIES INVOLVED
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS NOT
WORKABLE AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THAT SO I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. WITH THE SECOND. ANYBODY
ELSE. WHAT OTHERS WILL THINK YOU
GOT THAT IS ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE
LEGISLATION FOR WORKER
PROTECTION SAFETY AND-
DISCLOSURE OF PASTORING THIS
PANDEMIC AND- YOU KNOW I. WHEN
WHEN WE HAD NOTICES I DON'T
OFFICE IF THERE'S A NOTICE
ANYBODY IN THE BUILDING WILL BE
ONE THING. THAT GETS OUR
ATTENTION RIGHT AND THEN PEOPLE
CAN DECIDE HOW THEY WANT TO
RESPOND TO THAT OBVIOUSLY WAS A
LARGER SITUATION THAN AN
EMPLOYER WILL TAKE CERTAIN
ACTIONS. THE RIGHT TO KNOW.
ASIDE THEY WANT RESPOND EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE IN A I THINK
OBJECTIVELY BETTER SITUATION
NOW. THAN WE WERE IN THE PAST WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AROUND THE CORNER AND
CERTAINLY. THIS IS DEFINITELY A
BETTER SAFE THAN SORRY MEASURE
THAT I THINK IS IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THE RECOMMENDATION IS.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BILL
MOTIONS WAS A MEMBER WAR
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. THE SENATE RACES
LIKE TO CLOSE. I DO WANT TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR THE
COMMONS AND FURTHER ENGAGEMENT.
I THINK THAT- INITIALLY WE ALL
RECEIVED SO MANY NOT SO MANY.
NOTICES OF EXPOSURE. WE DON'T
GET THOSE AS OFTEN AS IS WE USED
TO AND I'M SURE IF THERE'S AN
UPTICK WE WILL TAKE NOTICE OF
THAT- BUT I. WHAT WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED WE NEED TO BE PREPARED
TO REACT IMMEDIATELY. SHOULD
THERE BE ANOTHER SURGE IN COVERT
NINETEEN CASES. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY TAKE WILL. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA FLOOR NO
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
REYES AYE REYES ICR DON'T KNOW
C. R. DON'T KNOW WARD. WORD I.
SPLIT THE BILLS UP. WE WILL MORE
LEFT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR. WHEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BERS.
ESTABLISHED OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA LABOR
CODE SECTION TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE
SEVEN YEAR STATUTE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF PROTECTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS FROM BEING TRAPPED
IN LONG TERM EMPLOYMENT
CONTRACTS BY PROHIBITING. THESE
CONTRACTS A LASTING NO LONGER
THAN SEVEN YEARS. THE ABILITY TO
TERMINATE A PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACT UP FOR SEVEN YEARS.
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO SEEK NEW
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OBTAIN IMPROVED TERMS WITH THEIR
CURRENT EMPLOYER. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THE RECORDING INDUSTRY LOBBY TO
EFFECTIVELY EXCLUDE RECORDING
ARTIST FROM SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE PROTECTIONS ARGUING
THAT RECORD COMPANIES MADE LARGE
INVESTMENTS OR ARTIST'S CAREER
BASED PRIMARILY ON THE PROMISE
THAT THE APPLE DELIVER A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF ALBUMS UNDER THE
CONTRACT. THE MUSIC BUSINESS HAS
ALSO UNDERGONE MASSIVE CHANGES
DUE TO DIGITAL MEDIA AND ONLINE
STREAMING. RECORD LABEL CENTER
PROFIT ENORMOUSLY FROM THE
JUDICIAL POP ONES BECAUSE THE
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTION
DISTRICT ASSOCIATED DEVELOPING
AN ARTIST. IS ONLY A FRACTION OF
WHAT IT USED TO BE. DESPITE
THESE GAINS RECORDING CONTRACTS
REMAIN OUTDATED THE TERMS
FAVORING THE RECORD LABELS. IN
THE MOTION PICTURE INDUSTRY MANY
ACTORS AND UNDER ARE UNDER
EXCLUSIVE CONTRACTS PROHIBIT
THEM FOR PERFORMING OR FINDING
WORK IN BETWEEN SESSIONS IN
BETWEEN SEASONS. THE ADVENT OF
NEW HOMES OF CONTENT
DISTRIBUTION LIKE STREAMING
SERVICES HAS DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED PRODUCTION SCHEDULES
ELIMINATING THE ABILITY OF
ANNUAL WORK SCHEDULES. THAT
INCLUDED CONSISTENT WORK FOR
NINE MONTHS AND ONLY SHORT
BREAKS BETWEEN SEASONS. TODAY
MANY TV AND NEW MEDIA SERVICE
SURE APOSTLES FOR ONLY FOUR TO
FIVE MONTHS PER SEASON I BELIEVE
ACTORS ON HOLD DURING THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR WITHOUT
WORK AND PAY. ACTORS AND
RECORDING ARTISTS HAVE LIMITED
WINDOWS OF OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICE THEIR CRAFT- LIVING AND
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES.
PROHIBITIOS ON THEIR ABILITY TO
WORK BETWEEN THE TELEVISION
SEASONS OR BETWEEN RECORDS LEAVE
NO ROOM TO ESTABLISH AND SUSTAIN
A CAREER. RECORDING ARTIST AND
ACTRESS PUT FOR TO LONG HAVE
BEEN HELD UNDER THE CONTROL OF
INDUSTRY WHO HAS ALL THE
LEVERAGE AND THE SIZE THEIR
ABILITY TO WORK AND THEIR
CAREERS AS AN ARTIST. AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY SIX THE FREE THIS
FROM INDUSTRY RESTRICTIONS ACT
OR FAIR ACT GIVES SOME OF THAT
CONTROL BACK TO THE WORKERS LONG
OF THE RESULTANT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WITH THEIR EMPLOYER.
ALL PROFESSIONAL ARTISTS WILL
STILL BE BOUND BY CONTRACTUAL
TERMS. AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX
WEEKS TO PUT AN END TO SOME OF
THE MOST UNFAIR PRACTICES THAT
STUDIOS AND RECORD LABELS USED.
TO UNILATERALLY HOLD ARTISTS OFF
THE JOB MARKET FOR UNREASONABLE
PERIODS OF TIME OR RESTRICT
THEIR FREEDOM TO WORK. I HAVE
HAD PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION WITH
THE OPPOSITION CRITIC WITH THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY AND I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE THESE TALKS WITH THE
BILL PASSED TO THE ARTS
COMMITTEE WITH ALL OPPOSITION.
WOULD BE REVIVED TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. ARE YOUR FOR GOOD WHEN
ACTRESS THE REPRESENTATIVE A SAG
AFTRA. AND WILL THE PROFITS
DIGGERS AND ACTIVISTS AND MUSIC
EXECUTIVE WITH THE BLACK MUSIC
UP UP WITH BLACK MUSIC ACTION
COALITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR TO FIRST WITH US PLEASE. HI
I'M JENNIFER GOODWIN I AM A FILM
AND TELEVISION ACTRESS AND MY
CAREER INCLUDES PROJECTS LIKE
HBO'S BIG LOVEABC'S ONCE UPON A
TIME. AND I VOICE JUDY HOPPS IN
THE DISNEY ANIMATED FEATURES
UTOPIA. I HAVE SUPPORTED MYSELF
AS AN ACTRESS FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT THAT PHRASE I JUST
USED I SUPPORT MYSELF I HAVE
SUPPORTED MYSELF AS AN ACTRESS.
I AM A BREADWINNER. AND MORE
MEANINGFULLY I'M ALSO A MOTHER
AND A WIFE AND MY HUSBAND ACTOR
JOSH DALLAS IS ALSO A
BREADWINNER. BECAUSE THESE DAYS
WE NEED AS MANY BREADWINNERS AS
WE CAN GET. MY HUSBAND HAS TAKEN
A JOB LIVING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FROM US HIS FAMILY SO THAT WE
CAN PAY FOR OUR HOUSE. CHILD
CARE AND SCHOOL TUITION. THIS
SITUATION PUTS ME IN A UNIQUE
POSITION TO SPEAK ABOUT
PERFORMERS RIGHTS. I'M HERE TO
PUT A FACE ON AN ISSUE THAT HAS
REAL WORLD CONSEQUENCES FOR
ARTISTS AND THOSE WHO RELY ON US
THE CALIFORNIA FAIRFAX THE FREE
ARTISTS FROM INDUSTRY
RESTRICTIONS ACT AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX. THIS IS
APPROPRIATELY NAMED BECAUSE IN
THIS WORLD WHERE STUDIOS
STREAMING SERVICES AN
INDEPENDENT PRODUCERS HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO CREATE ANYTHING THEY
WANT. IT IS THE VERY PERFORMERS
TO FILL THOSE SCREENS WHO ARE
DENIED THE FREEDOM TO WORK. WE
ARE IN SHORT REFUSED. E. SENSUAL
WORKER MOBILITY PROTECTION. LET
ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. MY
HUSBAND AND I HAVE BOTH IN
RECENT YEARS NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS FOR INDIVIDUAL
TELEVISION SEASONS. FIRST SERIES
COMPRISED OF TWENTY TWO EPISODES
. TWENTY TWO EPISODES IS AN
OUTDATED NETWORK STANDARD MY
SERIES LIKE MOST OTHER SERIES
WAS PICKED UP FOR ONLY TEN
EPISODES MY HUSBAND CHAU HAS
BEEN PICKED UP ANNUALLY FOR TEN
TO SIXTEEN EPISODES DEPENDING ON
THE YEAR AND WE ARE NOT
COMPENSATED FOR THE EPISODES WE
CANNOT ON BUT WHICH WE NEVER
SHOOT AND GUESS WHAT. WE ARE
FORCED TO SIT AND WAIT FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR OR MAYBE
THE STUDIO'S EXTENDER CONTRACTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALLOWED TO DO
THAT MAYBE IT'S A YEAR AND A
HALF. WE ARE FORCED TO SIT AND
WAIT UNEMPLOYABLE BY OTHERS
BECAUSE- WHAT IF THOSE WHO WILL
THE CENTER CONTRACT DECIDE THAT
THEY WANT TO SHOOT ANOTHER
SEASON. WE ARE CAPPED OFF THE
MARKET NOW SOME OF OUR BOSSES.
HIM WE WILL CALL ORIGINAL
EMPLOYERS. ASSERTS THAT THERE
ACTORS ARE ALLOWED TO TAKE WHAT
WE WILL CALL OTHER JOBS DURING
OUR HOLDING PERIODS. AS LONG AS
SAID OTHER JOBS ARE DEEMED NON
COMPETITIVE PROJECTS IN WE WILL
NOT WASTE OUR TIME UNPACKING OUT
HERE TODAY IT'S SUCH A
RIDICULOUS CONCEPT WHAT WE WILL
SAY IS OTHER JOBS. WON'T TOUCH
PERFORMERS WELL WE ARE HELD
UNDER CONTRACT BY ORIGINAL
EMPLOYERS ANYWAY. WHY WOULD
OTHER JOBS HIRE US. ORIGINAL
EMPLOYERS RETAIN THE RIGHT TO
PULL US OFF OF OTHER JOBS THAT
AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT. SHUTTING
DOWN OTHER JOBS AND POTENTIALLY
COSTING THEM MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. OTHER JOBS HAVE NO
INTEREST IN THAT LEGAL NIGHTMARE
AND AVAILABILITY RISK. AND I
DON'T BLAME THEM SO HERE WE ARE.
WE ARE ACTORS AND SNARED IN AN
UNFAIR EXCLUSIVITY CLAUSE WHICH
IS ONLY A REMNANT OF THE DAYS
WHEN STUDIOS CONTROL THE LIVES
OF PERFORMERS. NO CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATURE BEGAN DISMANTLING
THAT SYSTEM ALMOST EIGHTY YEARS
AGO. THERE IS STILL SO MUCH
PROGRESS TO BE MADE. AS A
CALIFORNIA I ASK YOU TO TAKE A
STAND FOR THE CREATIVE WORKERS
TO THRIVE HERE TO FILL YOUR
SCREENS WHO HELPED MAKE THE
STATE THE ENVY OF THE WORLD
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS LED THE
WAY AND IN KEEPING I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE PASS THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
ACT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR ASKING HE BECOMES A TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. EXILE PROFITS
FIGURES AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MUSIC
COMMUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT. FOR AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX THE FAIR AT.
CALIFORNIA HAS A STRONG
TRADITION OF PROTECTING CITIZENS
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE SECTION
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE KNOWN AS THE
SEVEN YEAR STATUTE CALIFORNIA
PROTECTED EVERYONE FROM BEING
TRAPPED IN UNFAIR PROTRACTED
CONTRACTS. FOR DECADES ALL
CALIFORNIANS WERE TREATED
EQUALLY TO SEEK SHELTER. FROM
DISPATCHING BY THE EIGHTEEN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE MAJOR
LABEL USED THEIR POWER TO AMEND
THE SEVEN YEAR STATUTE AND
EFFECTIVELY EXCLUDING ALL THIS
FROM THE STATUES PROTECTION THAT
WAS WRONG. AND UNFAIR. ARE THESE
SHOULD NOT SHOULD RECEIVE THE
SAME PROTECTION AS EVERY THER
CALIFORNIA THERE'S NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE THREE
MAJOR LABELS WERE COLLECTIVELY
VALUED AT A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS TO RECEIVE MORE
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT THE OTHER
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE LET ME
DISPEL ONE MYTH LABEL DO NOT
MAKE UP FOR INVESTMENTS THAT
COVER MULTIPLE ALBUMS RECORD
CONTRACTS ARE PAY AS YOU GO
MODEL WILL LABELS UNILATERALLY
DECIDE WHETHER TO MOVE AHEAD OR
NOT. IT IS IT IF THE LABEL IS
MAKING MONEY THE DROP THE ARMY'S
IN THAT IN THE IN IN THE N THE
INVESTMENT KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
LABEL STILL OWNS AND EXPORTS THE
OTHERS COPY RIGHT AFTER WE ARE
THIS IS GOING TO RESULT IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CHANGE
RECORD CONTRACTS WITH THE LATE
TODAY ARE INDENTURED SERVITUDE
IS THAT SIMPLE THE TERM FOR
RECORD CONTRACTS ARE EQUITABLE
BECAUSE THE LABELS HAVE ALL OF
THE POWER AND WITHOUT THE- NOPE
. OKAY WHAT BE CREATED COMMUNITY
. THEY HAVE GIVEN US A SIGN SO
MY- THE BILL. OR LOSE THEIR
PROTECTION AS A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR FINANCIAL GAINS
FOR RECORD COMPANIES. THIS IS
THE ISSUE OF SOCIAL AND RACIAL
JUSTICE THE MAJORITY OF OUR
THESE DRIVING PROFITS TODAY ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THE HEADS OF
THE MAJOR LABELS AND BOARD
MEMBERS WHO BENEFIT FROM THOSE
PROFITS ARE NOT. COMING TODAY
REPRESENT OUR THIS THAT MAKE THE
MUSIC THAT WE ALL LOVE THE FILM
THAT HAS THE SUPPORT OF ALL OF
THE GROUPS REPRESENTING WORKING
MUSICIANS BLACK MUSIC ACTION
COALITION CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF LABOR THE MUSIC ARTISTS
COALITION THE RECORDING ACADEMY
AT AFRO SO NOT AMONG OTHER
THINGS THE ONLY OPPOSITION TO
THE FACT OTHER MAJOR LABELS WHO
ARE DESPERATELY TRYING TO HOLD
IT TO A SYSTEM THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY LARGE THEIR
POCKETS AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
PROMISE WE ARE NOT LOOKING FOR
THIS ASSEMBLY. TO FIX ALL ALL.
OF THE- WE ARE LOOKING FOR YOU
TO RESTORE JUSTICE TO PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT'S OF THE STATE. THANK
YOU SOME OF THOSE COMMENTS.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. MAVEN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS MUCH TIGHTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY SUPPORT. CNN MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN SHARKS
THE PARTS PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
CRYSTALLINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMES DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MEXICO LIKE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEBLY SUSAN
GENCO ON BEHALF OF MUSIC
CREATORS IN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MEXICO LIFE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF YOU CAN AND CAN'T AND
DATA ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
I ASKED THE COUNCIL STRONG
SUPPORT. THE GROWING SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST IT
BURST ON BEHALF OF THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS TOTALING
EIGHTY NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS NOT IT HE ON
BEHALF OF AN OUTSPOKEN TALENT IN
SUPPORT. HELLO ADDITIONAL LINES
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WE MOVED OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX
OPPOSITION COME UP. TO SEE WHAT. JUST OF THE OPPOSITION AS WE
RAN A LITTLE BIT LONG ON ON THE
SUPPORT SO GIVE ABOUT SEVEN
MINUTES TO JUST CAN MAKE UP FOR
THAT TIME AS WELL. SO SEVEN
MINUTES MY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S MITCH
GLAZIER AND THE CHAIRMAN AND CEO
OF THE RECORDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHT NINE
TWENTY SIX. I SPEAK ABOUT THE
WORK SOME RECORDING SIDE OF THE
BILL AND THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL DON'T ADDRESS THE EXAMPLES
THAT ARE ADVANCE BUT THE
SUPPORTERS BUT IT WILL HAVE TO
HAVE THIS CONSEQUENCES WHEN HIS
MUSIC COMMUNITY. AND ECONOMY
TODAY RECORDING ARTISTS ENJOY
THE ADVANCES AND ROYALTIES IN
HISTORY. WITH GREATER CHOICE AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND MORE PATHWAYS
TO THEIR FANS AND THE SUCCESS
THAN EVER. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR FLEXIBLE
CUSTOMIZED MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
AND ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN ARTISTS AND LABELS. AND
ENCOURAGES RISK TAKING AND
INVESTMENT IN NEW AND RISING
ARTISTS. AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX DECIMATES THIS MUTUALLY
REWARDING SYSTEM BENEFITING A
FEW SUPERSTAR ARTISTS. BY
SHIFTING INCOME INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AWAY FROM
DEVELOPING ARTISTS. IT'S SIMPLY
UNTRUE THAT THIS BILL PROVIDES
NEW PROTECTION TO ARTISTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA SEVEN YEAR RULE. CAN
ALREADY FROM ANY RECORDING
AGREEMENT AFTER SEVEN YEARS AND
I THINK THAT BEARS REPEATING
ARTISTS CAN ALREADY UNDER
CURRENT LAW WALK AWAY FROM ANY
RECORDING AGREEMENT AFTER SEVEN
YEARS. THE BILL SIMPLY
ELIMINATES THE LABELS RECOURSE
WHEN AN ARTIST HASN'T DELIVERED
THE RECORDINGS THEY AGREED TO
MAKE AND WERE PAID FOR DURING
THAT TIME. THAT'S A PRETTY
RADICAL AND UNSUSTAINABLE NOTION
TO TAKE AWAY ONE SIDE'S ABILITY
TO ENFORCE A CONTRACT
EFFECTIVELY RENDERING IT VOID.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX ALSO
PLACES SEVERE AND UNPRECEDENTED
RESTRICTIONS ON ARTIS. IT'LL
HAMPER THEIR ABILITY TO
RENEGOTIATE AND DETER THEIR
RECORD COMPANY FROM EXERCISING
OPTIONS BECAUSE ITS STATUTORILY
CONTROLS IMPORTANT FLEXIBLE AND
NEGOTIATED CONTRACT PROVISIONS
THAT ALLOW PERIODS TO TOUR. OR
TO OBTAIN MORE FAVORABLE CONCERT
DATA TO DEMONSTRATE SUCCESS
GOING FORWARD. THE LAW MAKES
VERY PERSONAL BUSINESS DECISIONS
LIMITING OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
ABILITY TO ESTABLISH MEANINGFUL
PARTNERSHIPS. AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX AS DESTABILIZATION OF
RECORDING AGREEMENTS WOULD LEAD
TO REDUCED ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO
ARTISTS. LESS INVESTMENT IN THE
SIGNING DEVELOPMENT AND
PROMOTION OF NEW ACTS. IT WOULD
DETER CREATIVE SIX UNDERMINING
NON COMMERCIAL GENRES AND
ARTISTS SEEKING TO BREAK NEW
GROUND. ALL IN FAVOR OF WELL
ESTABLISHED WEALTHY ARTISTS WHO
ALREADY HAVE LEVERAGE. LABELS
LIKE ARTISTS ONE OF THE WELCOMES
FLEXIBILITY DIVERSITY INVESTMENT
AND RISK IN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX JEOPARDIZES ALL OF
THAT. SO WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX AND
ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
PERFORMANCE LEFT. A CHAIR KALRA
VICE CHAIR FLUORIDE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MELISSA
ATTACK AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION
AND OUR MEMBERS DISNEY
NBCUNIVERSAL NETFLIX PARAMOUNT
SONY PICTURES AND WARNER
BROTHERS MPA'S MEMBERS ARE
LEADING PRODUCERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS OF MOTION PICTURES
TELEVISION AND STRIP SERIES. ALL
EXHIBIT PLATFORMS THE THEATERS
TO BROADCAST AND CABLE
TELEVISION INTERNET AND
STREAMING SERVICES THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TEST TODAY.
IN OUR MEMBER OF OPPOSITION
RESPECT OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
OUR OUR OBJECTIONS FOCUS ON
SUBSECTION II OF THE BILL. FIRST
THE BILL WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
DISRUPT EXISTING CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN PRODUCERS
AND ARTISTS BY VOIDING
EXCLUSIVITY TERMS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN NEGOTIATED AND ON
WHICH BOTH THE PRODUCERS AND
ARTISTS RELY. SECOND THE BILL
WILL AT THE END OF THE LONG
STANDING PRINCIPLE THEIR
EMPLOYEE SHOULD DIRECT THEIR
FULL ATTENTION TO ONE EMPLOYER
AT A TIME. THIS PRINCIPLE IS
BASED IN PART ON THE PRACTICAL
REALITY THAT ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYMENT IS MORE LIKELY TO
CREATE CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND
IMPACT JOB PERFORMANCE AND THE
VACANT SUBJECTIVE TERMS SUCH AS
DIRECT SCHEDULING CONFLICTAND
MATERIALLY INTERFERE WITH THE
EMPLOYER'S BUSINESS WILL LEAD TO
A FLOOD OF LITIGATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER PARTICULAR.
MEET THE OUTPOST IT'S- THIRD
EXCLUSIVITY CLAUSES WHICH ARE
PART OF INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYMENT
CONTRACTS ARE EXTENSIVELY
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN PRODUCERS AND
ARTISTS. BOTH PARTIES BRING
THEIR SIGNIFICANT MARKET POWER
TO THESE NEGOTIATIONS AND IT IS
THROUGH THESE NEGOTIATIONS THAT
EACH PARTY BENEFITS THE ARTIST
THROUGH GREATER COMPENSATION AND
THE PRODUCER FOR SECURING THE
ARTIST AVAILABILITY WHICH
INSURES THE PROJECT STABILITY.
NOT ONLY FOR THE ARTISTS PREFER
THE HUNDREDS OF OTHERS EMPLOYED
ON A PARTICULAR PROJECT. FOURTH
ARTISTS ARE TYPICALLY WELL
COMPENSATED FOR PROVIDING THEIR
SERVICES ON AN EXCLUSIVE BASIS
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX WOULD
STRIP AWAY AN ARTIST'S ABILITY
TO NEGOTIATE FOR HIGHER
COMPENSATION IN EXCHANGE FOR
PROVIDING THEIR SERVICES
EXCLUSIVELY. AND FINALLY AND BY
NO MEANS LEAST IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION IS THAT THIS BILL
UNDERMINES DECADES OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING BETWEEN PRODUCERS AND
THE LABOR ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT VARIOUS ARTISTS GROUPS
IN MOTION PICTURE TELEVISION AND
STREAMING PRDUCTION. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THIS WAS A TOPIC OF
NEGOTIATION BETWEEN THE
PRODUCERS AND SAG AFTER DURING
THEIR NEGOTIATIONS SO I GOT FOR
MADE A PROPOSAL THE PRODUCERS
RESPONDED AND THEN SAG AFTRA
MOVED ON TO OTHER PRIORITIES. AT
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE WRITERS
GUILD AND THE PRODUCERS THE
WRITERS GUILD MADE ADVANCES AND
AS A RESULT OF THOSE NICKEL. THE
FAT SALARY THRESHOLD FOR
EXCLUSIVITY WAS RAISED BY 60% TO
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER PRODUCTION
JOB ON AND THAT'S TO WIN FIFTY
THOUSAND IN THE CASE OF
CHILDREN'S PROGRAMMING WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT OUR PRODUCER COULD
NOT HAVE THE EXCLUSIVE SERVICES
OF A WRITER ON A TV SERIES. IF
THAT WRITER IS PAID LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS DURING THE
PRODUCTION PERIOD. AND MORE TO
THE POINT WITHOUT REALLY GETTING
TIED UP IN THE SPECIFICS THE
PARTIES NEGOTIATE THIS ISSUE AND
THEY'VE REACHED AGREEMENTS. TO
BARGAINING. MINIMUMS AND
THRESHOLDS FOR EXCLUSIVITY THIS
LAST LEGISLATION YOU SERVICE
THAT PROCESS. THE BILL HAS WIDE
RANGING IMPACT ACROSS MORE THAN
AND THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
AND WITHIN THE ENTERTAINMENT IS
INDUSTRY IT WILL IMPACT MORE
THAN JUST SCRIPTED. TV AND
STREAMING MOVIE PROJECTS FOR
EXAMPLE. A NEWS NETWORK WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO SECURE THE
EXCLUSIVE SERVICES OF A NEWS
ANCHOR AND INVEST IN THAT NEWS
PROGRAM IN AN EFFORT TO BEAT THE
COMPETITION. THE ANCHOR COULD
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH ONE NETWORK
MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY AND BE
THE WEEK- ON A COMPETITIVE
STATION I SEE THE TIME IS LAPSED
LET ME JUST CONCLUDE. I DID
PROVIDE YOU WITH MY PREPARED
TESTIMONY THERE ARE OTHER
EXAMPLES IN THE PREPARED
TESTIMONY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE WERE MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY SCRIPTED SERIES UP
FROM TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
IN TWENTY ELEVEN. BOB AND THIS
DOESN'T INCLUDE LONGER FOR
PRODUCTIONS LIKE UP FEATURE
FILMS THIS IS EXPLOSIVE
EXPANSION ENTERTAINMENT PROGRAM
ACROSS ALL PLATFORMS HAS CREATED
NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL THE
TALENTED AND CREATIVE
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK IN THIS
SECTOR AND IT'S DRIVEN ECONOMIC
GROWTH. AB TWENTY NINE TO. PUT
ALL OF THIS AT RISK AND WE ASK
YOU TO VOTE AGAINST THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MUCH YOU TO. IN ONE UP TOP IS
XIN. HIS NAME IS A PLEASE-
ACTUALLY HOFFA ON WE HAVE THE
CAL CHAMBER OR BLOCK THANK YOU.
D. ON A SATURDAY WITH BROWN
STEEN ON BEHALF OF WARNER
BROTHERS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. SORRY MARGARET GLAD SHE KNOW
BEHALF OF UNIVERSAL MUSIC GROUP
IN OPPOSITION. JERRY MCCUE
REPRESENTING WARNER MUSIC GROUP
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TRANSMETAL OUT FOR THE WALT
DISNEY COMPANY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM SEEN NONE
SAMATAR IT'LL GO THE PHONE LINES
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. CLICK IN THE
TREMENDOUS DROP SESSION PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ENTER ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. PRESSBURGER
LINE SEVENTY LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KAYLA
TURNING ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION VIKA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. MICROCLINE SEVENTY
ACRE LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
DEAN OF THE PULSE OF THE MUSIC
WHERE REPRESENTING RECORDING
ARTISTS AND OTHER CREATIVES AND
I SUPPORT AB. TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX. MEXICO EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
SANTA GOT SEVENTY SIXERS OFFICE
IF YOU. REXEL IN EIGHTY TWO YEAR
LANA'S A COMPLETE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHOICE ON BEHALF
OF THE NBC UNIVERSAL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HELLO ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HEY
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
. GREAT- WE COVER A LOT OF
SUBJECTS IN- IN THIS- WELL IN
THAT THE LEGISLATURE EXPERIENCE
AND CERTAINLY IN THIS COMMITTEE-
IT IS BEEN ONE OF THE MORE
INTERESTING ONES TO REALLY-
DIGEST AND- BECOME INFORMED AND-
CERTAINLY BOTH OUR- INDUSTRY
PARTNERS AND OUR WORKERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I HAD A REALLY STRONG
MENTALITY TO OUR ECONOMY- AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR EVERYBODY
BEING OUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WANT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE THIS WORK- AND WHAT'S
FAIRNESS FOR ALL- AS I'VE BEEN
COMING AND TAKING SEVERAL
MEETINGS- IN BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION UP OF THIS BILL- JUST
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS THAT I REALLY
WANTED BE ABLE OUT THERE- I KNOW
THIS WAS. REALLY THE SUCCESSOR
TO AN EFFORT LAST YEAR THAT
BEGAN DEVELOPMENT- AND DURING
THAT TIME WE HAD THOUGHT ABOUT-
AND STILL REMAINS TODAY SEEMS TO
BE ARE THERE ARE THERE ARE TWO
BILLS IN BED AND ONE HERE- SORT
OF. THERE THERE'S A TIÞN AND
THEIR- A SOME SOME- CAN. TO
THESE ISSUES- BUT IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE-
IMPROVEMENTS FOR SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE TRYING TO
TACKLE WITH REGARD TO. THE FILM
AND TELEVISION INDUSTRY HERE. I
SEE THOSE AS POTENTIALLY
DISTINCT AND MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SOLVABLE- TO SOME OF THE
ONES THAT WHERE THEY WERE ALSO
TRYING TO DEBATE AND SOUL FOR
RECORDING ARTIST RECORDING
INDUSTRY HERE. SO ALL THE OFTEN
THE QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND
THEN MAYBE IF YOU WANNA- SORT OF
SUMMARIZES IT AND CLOSE- I DON'T
KNOW IF IT THE INTENTION DOWN
THE ROAD TO. BIFURCATE THIS BILL
AND REALLY TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE
BUT IT MIGHT- HELP TO SOLVE ONE
AND THEN REALLY FOR THE DEBATE
THE OTHER IS THAT THAT MIGHT
DESERVE A LITTLE BIT MORE MAYOR.
WITHIN THEIR MAYBE MAYBE TURN
TENSION TO KEEP THESE COMBINED-
FOR- HE FOR MUTUAL SUPPORT. EACH
OTHER'S ISSUES- THE ONYX CLUB
EXCLUSIVITY ISSUES I AGREE THAT
YOU KNOW TIMES HAVE CHANGED AND
CERTAINLY MÀ MEDIA HAS CHANGED
OPPORTUNITIES AND I'VE CHANGED
AND- YOU KNOW FROM FROM BOTH THE
THAT. NEED IN THE STREET. ALL
THE OPPORTUNE. FOR WORKER TO BE
ABLE TO- PUT THEMSELVES FORWARD
AND- WE CAPITALIZE ON ON THEIR
TALENT ON ON ON WHAT THEY'RE
OFFERING OUT THERE. AND THAT
SHOULD BE REWARDED- HI- I THINK
AS WELL ESPECIALLY AS THINGS ARE
FEELING A LITTLE BIT MORE FAST
PACED- I TRUST IN THE WORKERS.
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO MANAGE
THEIR TIME WELL ENOUGH TO- BE
ABLE TO MEET MULTIPLE DEMANDS IF
THEY ARE PRESENTING THEMSELVES
OUT THERE- WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE.
ABLE TO THEIR ORIGINAL
AGREEMENTS IF SOMETHING IS STILL
INTO A FACT- BUT I WOULD WANT TO
DEFER TO. THAT WORKER THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO MAKE. PAYMENTS
AND IF THERE'S SOMETHING DOWN
THE ROAD WHERE THEY- ARE IN
VIOLATION OF THE SECONDARY
EMPLOYER WHILE THEY'RE ON A SIX
MONTH BREAK- EXCUSE ME- THERE
INVIOLATE. THE PRIME- FOR
SOMETHING TO BE WORKED OUT
THROUGH. THAT THE SHOULD BE SEEN
AS- SOMETHING THAT THAT WOULD
RESOLVE ITSELF IN FAVOR OF THAT
THAT THAT PRIMARY EMPLOYER
SOMETHING THAT THE- EMPLOYEE- I
WOULD NOT WANT TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES. ADDED IN THAT
POSITION AND THEN THE- WOULD DO
THEMSELVES WELL TO WORK THAT'S
ALL WILL WORK THAT OUT- BUT I
DON'T WANT TO CONSTRAIN THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES IF- IT MEANS THAT
IN THE MOMENT THEY CAN. HAVE A
LITTLE SIDE WORK HAVE BEEN ON
THE SIDE OF OR TO ANY THAT WOULD
NOT MATERIALLY CONFLICT. WITH
SOME OF THAT PRIMARY WORK AND
I'D LIKE TO SEE. I LIKE. THE
BILL'S GOING UP ON THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY SIDE OF SOME OF THESE
ISSUES- YOU KNOW I FUNDAMENTALLY
THINK THAT THERE'S- THERE IS A
FOLLOW HERE THAT A CONTRACT IS A
CONTRACT AND I KNOW THEIR
INVESTMENTS MADE EARLIER ON AND
I KNOW THE ALSO THE INDIVIDUALS-
ME TAKE OFFAND THEY MAY BE VERY
WELL- THROUGHOUT THEIR INITIAL
EXPERIENCES AND- THEY MAY WANT
TO SEE- THE TERMS OF CHANGED
THEIR THEIR THE STATUS HAS
CHANGED AND- AND- EVEN WITHIN
YOU KNOW A SEVEN YEAR PERIOD-
THAT ME WARRANT YOU KNOW
RENEGOTIATION THAT MAY WARRANT
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THEM.
SOMETHING THAT. THAT THIS IS WHY
HAVING A MORE CHOI WITH IT
THOUGH- IF YOU ARE REQUIRED TO
DELIVER ON FOUR ALBUMS. SINCE
DELIVER ON THOSE FOUR ALBUMS-
AND BE DONE WITH AND WALK AWAY
IF THE RELATIONSHIP IS NOT
HEALTHY- JUST EVERY SIDE
COMPLETE THEIR WORK I'M STILL
HAVING TROUBLE ON THIS SIDE OF
THE BILL. FIGURING OUT WHY
THERE'S ACTUALLY NOT ZONE OF
AGREEMENT HERE- I WOULD LIKE IT
TO MOVE FORWARD AND I KNOW THIS
IS GOING TO GO TO THE ARTS
COMMITTEE AND THEY'LL BE AT
THINKING EVEN DEEPER DISCUSSION
ON THE COMMITTEE HAS
JURISDICTION IS MAYBE A LITTLE
BIT MORE. FOCUSED ON THE SUBJECT
AREA OF THIS BILL BUT I JUST
LEADERS- TO THE AUTHOR AS KIND
OF OBSERVATIONS- AND IN TERMS.
OF THE THAT DICEY WITH THIS THAT
THAT I HOPE WE'LL ON. MATURE
AND- WILL- WILL GET STRESSED
OUT. ABOUT THE LICENSE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THERE ARE- RIGHT
SWINGS FOR EVERYBODY HERE THAT
THAT WILL MAKE IT A BETTER
WORKING ENVIRONMENT FOR- OUR
TALENT- BUT ALSO- ONE THAT
DOESN'T VIOLATE ANY ISSUES OF
FAIRNESS FOR. OUR EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE INDUSTRIES HERE IN IN THE
STATE THAT THAT WE WANT TO KEEP
YOUR ROOM WANT TO KEEP. KEEP
HEALTHY AND BE FAIR TO THEM AS
WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SOMEONE WOMAN. REYES THANK YOU
MISTER. I WON'T BELABOR THE
COMMENTS THAT MIGHT MIGHT
DISTINCT COLIC HAS ALREADY
SHARED TONIGHT- IT IS IT JUST AS
SOON MISTER WARD I TO HAVE TAKEN
MANY- MEETING WITH MANY OF THE
PROPOSED SITE FROM BOTH SIDES. I
HAVE GREAT CONFIDENCE ALSO IN
OUR COLLEAGUE WHO CHAIR CHUCK-
KALRA WHO HAS TAKEN ON THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY TO FIND
THE RIGHT SOLUTION THE RIGHT
BALANCE. OF WHEN WE HAVE TWO
PARTIES- SPEAK ALSO IS AN
ATTORNEY MR WARD YOU HAVE TWO
SIDES. IF THEY ARE BOTH.
NEGOTIATING FROM THE SAME LEVEL
THEN IT'S EASY TO SAY IT'S FAIR.
TO DO SIGNING YOU'RE DONE BUT
WHEN THERE ISN'T THAT YOU'RE NOT
NEGOTIATING FROM THE SAME LEVEL
THEN THERE IS A PROBLEM THERE
AND I THINK SOMETIMES IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO THEN LOOK AT
THOSE CONTRACTS. TO DETERMINE IF
THERE IS. UNFAIRNESS THEN WE DO
NEED TO STEP IN TO HELP PICK IN
IT IN IN THAT PROCESS. A
CONTRACT IS A CONTRACT AND IF
YOU HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY OF
RESPONSIBILITY WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY CONTRACTS
IN THE PAST THAT HAVE BEEN
ILLEGAL CONTRACTS. AND I WON'T
GO INTO ONE BELIEVER THAT. WE
WANT TO SOLUTION TO THIS WITHOUT
A DOUBT- THE VERY FIRST COMMENT
FROM MY COLLEAGUE WAS HOW
IMPORTANT THE INDUSTRY IS. BOTH
IN. THE FILM INDUSTRY AND THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY SO IMPORTANT
TO CALIFORNIA. AND TO HAVE BOTH
PARTIES BE ABLE TO MEET TOGETHER
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THIS IS GOING TO THE ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT. COMMITTEE AND
I KNOW THAT- CHAIR-
BOERNER HORVATH IS LOOKING
FORWARD. MAYBE THAT'S NOT THE
RIGHT WORD RIGHT. WHAT ALL OF
YOU. COME AND SHARED THAT THIS
YEAR YOUR SIDES. BUT I THINK
THAT THIS BILL ABSOLUTELY
DESERVES TO MOVE FORWARD SO THAT
THE CONVERSATIONS CAN CONTINUE
SO THAT THE PARTIES CAN THEN
DETERMINE HOW BEST TO THAT
PRESENTED. TO THE BODY WHEN WE
TAKE TO THE FLOOR. SO WITH THAT
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RIGHT AND I. TO WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE MORE DISCUSSION ON
THIS I DON'T KNOW THIS BUSINESS
MODEL OF JUST. WHETHER IT'S ON
THE ON THE- PRODUCTION SIDE OF
REDDISH RECORDS OR WHETHER IT'S
MOVIES- I KNOW ARE YOU KNOW WHEN
I ASKED ABOUT RETURN ON
INVESTMENTS. FOR R&D I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE IN OTHER BUSINESS
ENTITIES WHEN YOU PUT THAT
INVESTMENT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU GET YOUR INVESTMENT BACK- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WHAT IS TO BE
GREAT. THE BEST FORMULA FOR
STUDIOS AND MUSIC COMPANIES TO
BE ABLE TO GET BACK THERE ARE A
WIDE TO RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
AND BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
BANKRUPT DAYS AT IT WILL BE
IDIOTS LIKE PUT A GUN TO OUR
HEADS IF WE WERE TO TRY TO
BANKRUPT IN. INDUSTRY THAT IS
NOT ANYTHING ANYBODY UP HERE
WANTS TO DO OR ANYBODY IN THE
CAPITAL- YOU ARE THRIVING
INDUSTRY THAT KEEPS US AFLOAT
AND ALIVE. ON THE OTHER HAND YOU
HAVE TO STINK OUT COMPENSATION
AND IN MY- YOU KNOW I. I RETIRED
FROM THE CITY OF LA AND SOMEBODY
MAKING THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND- IF YOU DO
IT CHILDREN SO IT'S TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND THAT'S A LOT OF
pIN IN MY MIND- AS YOU WERE
SAYING THEY GET. WELL
COMPENSATED. SO IN IN MY WORLD
IN MY MIND IF YOU TALK TO ANY
OF. ANY CIVIL SERVANTS IN HIS
BUILDING. THEY WOULD. THEY WOULD
RAISE THEIR EYEBROWS AT THAT
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WHERE MY CONFUSION
COMES WHEN I ASKED ABOUT- HE TO
GET TELEVISION THE TO YOU BUT
WHEN ASKED ABOUT CYNTHIA NIXON
WHOSE IN DOVER WHAT'S THAT THE
GOLDEN AGE AND- AND JUST LIKE
THAT SHE'S IN TWO DIFFERENT
MAJOR PRODUCTIONS BUT I'M ALSO
HEARINGS EXCLUSIVITY THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP OUR ONLY IN ONE
BOTH THE MAJOR MAJOR- PRODUCTION
SO HOW DID SHE GET A DIFFERENT
DEAL WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EXCLUSIVITY HERE TO CHOOSE THE
STUDIO'S REALLY WANT THE SAME
WITH- I WANT TO TALK TO
RECORDING ENTRY- GET I DON'T
SOUND START STARTS ROBERT MAJOR
BRIANNA OR THEY MAY TO RE ON AND
THE FACT THAT SHE DOES. THE
RIGHT MAKE UP AND MOVIES AND
THIS AND THAT AND SHE MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE COMPLETED ALL OF HER
ALBUMS AT THE SAME I BET SHE'S-
TO THE RECORDING INDUSTRY SO
DOES THAT EXTEND HER TIME- AS
FAR AS BEING UNDER CONTRACT AND
HOW IS THAT MONEY GETS SPLIT UP
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THEY DON'T.
SHARE IN IT BUT THE RECORDING.
FOURTEEN THE ARE SAYING YOU'RE-
SO THAT'S WHERE MY- I'M GETTING
MIXED INFORMATION I DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO BE ACTUALLY DELVE
INTO IT TO ACTUALLY GET- WHAT'S
REALLY REALLY GOING ON- WITH
SWITCH YOUR WITH YOUR CONTRACT
IN YOUR WORLD. I REALLY WOULD
LIKE FOR THIS TO BE BIFURCATED
AND I THINK THE- CHAIRMAN WILL
PROBABLY ADDRESS SOME OF THAT-
AS WEAK AS YOU MOVE FORWARD- BUT
FOR ME. IT'S REALLY ABOUT TRYING
TO FIND OUT WHAT REALLY. WORKS
FOR BOTH SIDES. AND WELL WHILE I
MAY WANT THIS TO COME GET OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE IF IT MAKES IT TO
THE FLOOR. I MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENT. LOOK AT IT BUT WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T STOP HERE. AND THAT WE
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION BUT
MOST IMPORTANT THAT WE THIS
COMMITTEE AND EVERY MEMBER AT
THIS POINT. MEMBER THE NEXT TO
ME BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IF IT
MAKES IT TO THE FLOOR. THAT
EVERY MEMBER REALLY UNDERSTANDS-
YOUR BUSINESS MODEL YOU ARE. IF
YOU'RE A BUSINESS MODEL. FOR THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS PROBABLY DIDN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE BECAUSE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF MONEY AND
BUT YOU TALK ABOUT IN A WAY.
WHERE IT'S NOT A LOT OF MONEY
AND SO- BUT IF IT WOULD HELP US
TO UNDERSTAND- WHY THINGS HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN THE PAST. AND
HOPEFULLY THERE'S A GOOD
DIALOGUE WITH THE ARTIST. THE
EMPLOYEES WHY IS NOT WORK FOR
THEM THE SEVEN YEAR- I DID NOT
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS BECAUSE THIS
WILL BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME-
AND NOT THAT I'M NOT DISCOUNTING
THE MOTION PICTURE SIDE OF IT
BUT THIS IS THIS IS PROBABLY A
AN EXAMPLE OF WHY I'M- I'M I'M
NOT TOTALLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE. WHERE WHAT THE
ALBUM IS AN ALBUM THAT ALBUM TO
ME THE BUNCH OF RECORDS I GIVE
IT TO YOU IT'S AN ALBUM. BUT IF
YOU BELIEVE THAT I NEED TO GET
THIRTEEN SONGS AND I GIVE YOU
TEN BUT THAT DOESN'T COUNT AS AN
ALBUM AND YOU TELL ME I STILL
OWE YOU AN ALBUM BUT I GAVE YOU
TEN SONGS INSTEAD OF THIRTEEN.
HOW IS THAT IS THAT NEGOTIATED
SETTLEMENT WITH HIS WERE ALREADY
NEGOTIATING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING SO YOU ACTUALLY KNOW
WHAT WHAT THAT IS- BECAUSE
THAT'S THE KIND OF I'VE DONE
COLLECTIVE BARGAIN I KNOW WHAT.
I KNOW WHAT THAT IS AND I'M A
LITTLE MORE PRECISE PRECISE IN
MY CALCULATIONS THE DUES NO
AMBIGUITY AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
FURTHER DIALOGUE ON WHAT WHAT AT
THE NOW WAS AN ALBUM JUST LIKE
ON. THE MOTION PICTURE SIDE. I
CAN. CAN YOU HOLD SOMEONE AT AND
I JUST AND PRODUCTION SCHEDULES
AND YOU YOU KNOW YOU GOTTA GET
YOUR MOVIE OUT YOU'RE AT A
GREASE I USED TO GO TODAY'S
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF MONEY
A LOT OF PRODUCTION A LOT OF
CUSTOMS A LOT OF RESEARCH IS A
LOT A LOT A LOT A LOT IN IT. WAS
A LOT OF MONEY SO- YOU DON'T
WANT YOUR START TRAIPSING OFF
GOING SOMEWHERE WHEN YOU GOT ALL
THAT MONEY INVESTED IN THERE BUT
BUT THEN AGAIN I USED IN THE
CITY NIXON EXAMPLE WHERE'S
PROBABLY TWO MAJOR PRODUCTIONS
THEY'RE DOING STUFF SO I'D LIKE
TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT IF THIS WERE TO MAKE IT OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I'M I JUST ASK ON THAT
EXCLUSIVITY CLAUSE PART OF IT
MAYBE ONE OF THE SUPPORTERS CAN
COME UP WITH AN ANSWER BUT- IF
YOU ARE- PRODUCING A SERIES.
RIGHT N. N. YOU YOU CAST THAT
SERIES MAYBE I'LL JUST LOOK AT
ME BECAUSE I. WORK FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE'RE NOT. A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT WORLD BUT-
HOW DOES THAT WORK HOW CAN A
BUSINESS PLAN FOR THE LIFE OF
THE SERIES IF THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR TALENT. MIGHT FIND
ANOTHER JOB RIVER MOVING OUT OF
IT BACK TO THE CONTRACT SIDE OF
THIS THING. CAN YOU HELP WALK US
THROUGH THAT IS HOW CAN IT
WHETHER IT'S ABC OR WHOEVER
RIGHT PLAN FOR A SERIES OF
DURATION CAST IT THAT HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE TALENT IS
GOING TO STAY THERE. WELL
BECAUSE I SIGNED A CONTRACT I
WOULD STILL ABSOLUTELY BE TRUE
TO MY CONTRACT THAT SHOULD THIS
BE SCHEDULED TO SHOOT FROM
JANUARY TO MARCH I WOULD BE
COMPLETELY AVAILABLE TO YOU. BUT
BETWEEN MARCH AND THE FOLLOWING
JANUARY. I SHOULD BE A LAUGH
WILL TO TAKE A JOB IN WHAT WILL
CALL FIRST BECAUSE IT WILD THE
WHOLE THING WOULD BE ELIMINATING
THE POSITIONS. RIGHT NOW WHEN I
SIGNED A CONTRACT FOR A
TELEVISION SERIES I GIVE THAT
SERIES FIRST POSITION. NOW
TECHNICALLY THINGS HAVE BEEN SET
UP SO THAT I CAN TAKE A NON
COMPETITIVE PROJECT IN SECOND
POSITION. THE PROBLEM IS NOBODY
WANTS TO TOUCH ME FROM MARCH TO
JANUARY. BECAUSE WHAT IF THE
NETWORK DECIDES THAT THEY WANT
TO PICK US UP AND PUT US IN THE
FALL INSTEAD SO I HAVE TO WAIT
BUT I'M NOT GONNA BE COMPENSATED
FOR THAT WAIT I'M NOT EVEN GONNA
BE COMPENSATED FOR THE- YOU KNOW
FOR THE- TWELVE EPISODES I
DIDN'T SHOOT OF THE SEASON THAT
I FIND FOR TWENTY TWO. I KNOW
YOU PAY FOR THE TEN THAT I SHOT
AND THEN I'M GONNA WAIT AND SEE
WHAT THE NETWORK OR THE STUDIO
WHOEVER'S IN CHARGE ME DECIDES
TO DO WITH MY SHOW. AND THOUGH
THERE IS THIS EXCEPTION. THAT IS
YOU CAN TAKE SOMETHING IN SECOND
POSITION. ALL I CAN SAY IS LIKE
OFF THE BOOKS. ALL OF MY FRIENDS
THAT NETWORKS AND STUDIOS TELL
ME. YEAH BUT ONCE WE HEAR THAT
YOU'RE UNDER CONTRACT. WE DON'T
WANNA GET INTO IT WE DON'T WANT
TO RISK LOSING YOU. WE DON'T
WANT YOU TO COME TO WORK IT COST
US MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. FOR YOU
TO BE HONEST SET AND BE TOLD.
THEY DECIDED YOU'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO WORK TO REALLY FEEL LIKE
THERE'S ALSO. PART OF THIS. THAT
IS ABOUT JUST SCHEDULING
SCHEDULE LAST GIVE US A TIME
FRAME WHERE. YOU'RE GOING TO
SHOOT A MOVIE FOR SIX MONTHS.
YOU'RE GOING TO SHOOT- A
TELEVISION SERIES AND BE
AVAILABLE TEST FROM JANUARY TO
MARCH THIS YEAR. AND THEN YOU
CAN GO OFF AND DO OTHER WORK
WHEN YOU ARE NOT. EXACTLY ON A
SET BECAUSE I AM ONLY PAID WHEN
I AM PHYSICALLY ON THAT SET AND
YES. I AM OWNED. FOR THE REST OF
MY TIME FOR THE TERM OF THE
CONTRACT DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
YES THANK YOU. YES WILL HAVE TO
RESPOND I DON'T ON I'M NOT GOING
TO ADDRESS A SPECIFIC SAID
BECAUSE- THAT WAS A I UNDERSTAND
THE EXAMPLE IN THE SPECIFICS
AND- THEN SCHEDULE. WHAT WHAT I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE TENDS TO PAINT
WITH A BROAD BRUSH. AND I HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION. AS
HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOARD REFERRED
TO THIS AS AS DID ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. PRODUCTIONS
ARE UNIQUE SCHEDULING IS UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE UNIQUE WE DID
A SURVEY IN RESPONSE TO LAST
YEAR'S BILL. OF OUR MEMBERS WITH
SERIES REGULARS. AND WE THE
COMPANIES WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PERFORMERS ONLY
THE PERFORMER SIDE THIS. AGAIN
THIS BILL IS BROADER BECAUSE
IT'S ALL ARTISTS I CAN. JUST ON
THE PERFORMER SIDE. THAT ON.
THOSE ARTIST THE PERFORMERS WHO
CAME FORWARD WITH REAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. ON IN 95297% OF
THE SITUATIONS THAT WERE
PRESENTED TO THE COMPANIES. WERE
GRANTED A YES WAIVER AND SET. TO
GO OFF AND DO OTHER WORK AND IN
THE- BARGAINING CONTRACT IT
ALLOWS. FOR SPECIFIC KINDS OF
OTHER WORK. ON I DON'T WANT TO
DISTURB I'M NOT DISAGREEING
WITH- IS GOOD WHEN. THAT IT'S IT
IS SPECIFIC IT IF YOU'RE IN A
SERIES IT COULD BE A FEATURE
FILM IT COULD BE A COMMERCIAL
COULD BE VOICE OVER WORK. THERE
THERE ARE LOTS OF OTHER OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. AND THE POINT I
JUST WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH IS.
ONE SIZE FITS ALL WHICH IS WHAT
LEGISLATION TENDS TO BE. IT IS
GOING TO BE DISRUPTIVE. WHERE IS
IF YOU LEAVE US TO BE BETWEEN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND
BETWEEN INDIVIDUAL NEGOTIATIONS
BECAUSE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS
THE BASELINE. SETS AS A MINIMUM
STANDARD AND THRESHOLD. AND THEN
THE INDIVIDUALS COME IN WITH
THEIR INDIVIDUAL CONTRACTS. THAT
ALLOWS FOR THE ON THE NEW GO TO.
NAVIGATION I- OF INDIVIDUAL
SERVER. A AND SCHEDULES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. WAS THERE A
SECOND THE MOTION. SECOND STILL
CHECKING THANK YOU I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- YES AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE- BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I WOULD SAY
THAT UP ON THE EXCUSES
EXCLUSIVITY SIDE- THE TRUST THE
WORKERS IS CRITICAL AND FOR THE
NEED FOR IT TO WORK FOR BOTH
SIDES BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT
WORKING FOR BOTH SIDES RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT
ALL- WE HAVE A UNIT UNILATERAL
CHOICE OF THE STUDIO. WITH
LITTLE TO NO LEVERAGE AT THE
AFTER OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE A VERY
BIG NAME YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
MORE LEVERAGE BUT FOR THE FOR
THE FOR MOST OF THE WORKING
ACTORS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THAT LEVERAGE AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GETTING ALL THE POWER OF
EXCLUSIVITY TO ONE PARTY. AND
THAT'S WHAT THE PART PROBLEM IS
IF THERE WAS IF THERE WAS LEVELS
ON BOTH SIDES AND NOW THEY CAN
NEGOTIATE YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO
BE EXCLUSIVE LET'S NEGOTIATE
EXCLUSIVITY INTO THE CONTRACT WE
HAVE TAKEN THAT LEVERAGE
COMPLETELY AWAY. FROM THE ARTIST
THAT CASE ON THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY SIDE LOOK FOR A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE SECTION
TWO EIGHT FIVE FIVE TO SEVEN
YEAR STATUTE THAT IS DESIGNED.
TO PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING TRAPPED IN LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTS BY
PROHIBITING THESE CONTRASTS A
LASTING NO LONGER THAN SEVEN
YEARS THE ONE EXCEPTION IS
RECORDING ARTISTS IS ONLY IF IT
WAS AN EXCEPTION THAT WAS
LOBBIED FOR A IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY THE INDUSTRY BUT THEY
COULDN'T GET. LAWMAKERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY TO EXTEND IT TO
UP TO TEN YEARS. AND SO. YOUR
ROOM YOU'LL AT THAT. IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF I MEAN I'LL- THE SON A
MATTER OF IT WE JUST LOOK AT IT
IN TERMS OF HOLDING ONE TO A
CONTRACT LET'S REMEMBER. AS A
SUMMER REYES INDICATED THE
DIFFERENCE OF NEGOTIATING POWER
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUNGER ARTISTS.
ANOTHER ORDER INSTANTLY PUT IN A
SEVEN YEAR CONTRACT. NOW IT'S
ONE THING TO SAY OKAY YOU HAVE
TO HOLD YOUR SIDE OF THE
CONTRACT. BUT WHY IS THIS THE
ONLY SERVICE CONTRACT WERE ONCE
A SEVEN YEARS IS EXPIRED YOU'RE
STILL HELD. IN THAT CONTRACT IF
YOU HAVE A MONETARY DISPUTE YOU
CAN RESOLVE THAT MONETARY
DISPUTE. BUT THAT'S WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS OF THESE ARTISTS GET
HELD IN THESE CONTRACTS. AND
WORK THE WHOLE WE DON'T DO THAT
WITH OTHER WORKERS WE DON'T DO
THAT. WITH WE SHOULDN'T BE DOING
THAT THE ARTIST OF ANY KIND. AND
SO THIS IS ABOUT SELF
DETERMINATION. THIS IS ABOUT
FREEDOM. REALLY WHAT IT COMES
UNDER FREEDOM TO BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHERE DO YOU WORK FOR. IF
YOU HAVE A DEAL THAT HE SAID YOU
HAVE TO DO A B. AND C. YOU DO A
B. AND B. BUT YOU'RE AT THE END
OF SEVEN YEARS TO START WORKING
OUT. YOU SHOULD THE FREEDOM TO
STRIP TO LEAVE AND SICK OF THE
WORK AND THAT THERE SHOULD BE.
NO IF THEY WANT TO PURSUE OR YOU
WANNA TO MUTUALLY AGREE ON WHAT
THAT. WHATEVER WAS LEFT OF THE
CONTRACT TO DO OVER SHOULD KNOW
YOU COULD TRY TO GET YOU GREET
YOU GO TO THE COURT THE COURT
SYSTEM TO USE FOR THAT. DON'T
POINT IT. ALL THE TIME. BUT TO
SAY THAT YOU. TO BE. IN CONTRACT
OR EXTRA THE CONTRACT CONTINUES
TO EXTEND- IT IS JUST NOT JUST.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
IT'S A THIS IS A COMPUTER BOTH
TWO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRIES AND TE REASON WHY
SOMEONE TO LOOK THESE ARE BOTH
OUTDATED. COMPONENTS THAT ARE
AFFECTING ARTISTS. AND THEY ARE
REALLY CONNECTED TO AN INDUSTRY
THAT- THAT ALONG TIME AGO WAS
FAR MORE ONEROUS BUT I THINK
EVERYONE WOULD AGREE WITH THAT.
AND HAS IMPROVED IN MANY WAYS
BUT WE DO HAVE THESE REMNANTS
THAT IT'S UP TO US BECAUSE WE'RE
THE ONES THAT THAT CREATED THE
ISSUES THAT ARE EXISTING WE HAVE
ALSO SOLVED A LOT OF THEM OVER
THE DECADES. THERE ARE STILL
SOME LEFT TO GO AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OBJECTIVELY SCHOOL
OF. MOTION IS TO PASS TO ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE
KALRA HI KALRA HI LAURA FLORA NO
JONES SAWYER. I WE GETTING
INFORMATION RECORDS AND DAMAGES
. THIRTY INDUSTRY JONES SAWYER I
REYES SERLING WAS NO THERE ARE
NO KNOWN WAR. WAR I OPPOSE ON
THE CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BILLS UNCLE. YEAH OKAY. THANK
YOU VICE CHAIR OF THE CISCO
THROUGH THE REMAINING AFTER SOME
FOLKS I NEED TO VOTE ON THINGS
SO WE HAVE ITEM TWO WICKS I
THINK. YEAH SO I THINK- SUMMER
JONES SAWYER. NEWS TO RECORD OF
A LOT. AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I
WAS SICK OF THOSE UP ITEM THREE.
THERE'S AN ADD ON OR SOMETHING
SOMERS SO I WASN'T SURE IF ITEM
THREE IS THAT CORRECT. WELL HE
WAS HERE REYES OF REYES WITH
REPAIRS YEAH SO ITEM FOR IS ON
CALL ON A TWO TO VOTE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. JONES SAWYER.
AND I BELIEVE FLORIDA MAY NOT
APPEAR AS WELL AS A CAR NOW
HELLO SHE WAS RESULT OF RAISES
WELL SHOULD BE THE MOST BECAUSE
OF SUMMER JONES SAWYER A. B. HI
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER I REYES
BILLS BACK ON THE COURT AND-
THAT'S BACK ON CALL AND THEN WE
GO. I DON'T FIVE. CHOOSER JONES
SAWYER ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HI. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE
JONES SAWYER BY OKAY THAT'S OUT
ITEM SIX SORT OF THE OUTRAGEOUS
FORTUNES OUT HIS NINETY THREE IS
OUT EVERYBODY VOTED AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THREE. MEDINA REYES
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE REYES
STILL ON CALL OKAY SO IT'S
RECALL AB TWENTY NINETY FIVE. AB
TWENTY NINETY FIVE WE NEED WARD
. WARD HI THANK YOU THAT THOSE
OUT. AND WE JUST NEED A SUMMER
REYES I THINK EVERYBODY ELSE IS
A- FREE TO GO. GLOBAL HOLD ON
FOR A WHILE BEFORE YOU TURN.
PUBLIC WITH THE.
THIS TO ME THE ITEMS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS IS ON CALL. YEAH
THIS IS THIS IS THE WORKS BUT
I'M I'M SURE. WHICH IS DONE FOR
YOU. ITEM THREE BOERNER HORVATH
. AB TWENTY TWO OH FOUR RADIUS
RADIUS ON THE SOUTH SIDE.
WITHOUT ITEM FOR ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE GARCIA.
REYES HI REYES HI THE BILL THIS
SUMMER. EIGHT TWENTY ONE THIRTY
THREE AT EIGHT TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE MEDINA.
REYES REYES HI THE BILL SELTZER
. I TO NINETY BETWEEN NINETY
FIVE KALRA. SHE'S ON THE LINE
ITEM NUMBER AND SOCIAL. SERVICE
AB. HELLO I'M SO AB TEN A.
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY KALRA.
REYES HI REYES I THAT BILL IS
FILE THAT'S ALL COME WITH A
MEETINGS ADJOURNED THANK YOU.
YEAH.